j'ai envie de dire icare ont su à renens
salue les mecs je comprends pas ce truc
avec hikaru on voit su être partout et
j'aimerais pays disparaît de l'écran
j'ai pas compris en fait bon peu importe
bonsoir à tous donc bas aujourd'hui le
gros match avec maxime qui va jouer
contre eux vrai cela tu vas je conçois
ce lait est donc ça devrait commencer
dans trois à quatre minutes le temps de
bien que je vérifie bien que tout soit
comme il faut toujours triste comme un
pansement une petite pub de twitch ça a
été géré avec brio je vais essayer
d'ouvrir les bons chat est donc
aujourd'hui c'est le gros match
quand j'écris c'est la presse bref c'est
la presse chez pai maître robert est de
partout quoi way i ka jazz comme dans
leur délire avec hikaru aussi
complètement mais pas à tout le monde à
son délire haïti car ce type n'est pas
un athlète ce type n'est pas un athlète
salut gêne je crois au bruit cela sony s
ouais c'est la semi s jérôme qui faisait
qu'ils allaient mvl 10 ans parties
samedi kevin joss la russie qui demande
une grotte on va voir on va on va partir
à partir sur les chapeaux de roue à
partir tranquille aujourd'hui ça va être
un match long et serré et compliqué on
va prendre le temps hier hier beaucoup
de stries maillage pas si vous avez
suivi ou pas il ya eu le match lui a
prié le stream avec les avec les
téléspectateurs ont essayé de faire et
c'est ce que j'ai réussi à faire un faux
l'eau sur maxime on va voir est-ce que
je réussisse que dernièrement sur une
chaise comme j'ai plus de mal à faire
défaut look avant non mais ça
m'intéresse pas du tout la regrette
cette partie des dix diola dégagé je
veux pas vous voir
[Musique]
je vais essayer de le jumelle et quand
ils démarrent en fait j'essaie de
jumelles et maxime et salua blom salut
attitude u18 s'est dit plus c'est long
plus c'est bon est vrai après c'est
parfois c'est un peu trop long quoi hier
ça faisait un peu mal sur la fin
ce serait super un match serré mais je
pense aujourd'hui ça va être serré
je vois pas tu vois il nous met les
probas ils te mettent ils te mettent
même wesley so favori mais je sens en
fait qu'on restait sur les favoris mais
bon pas autant ça va être 55 45 ou un
truc comme ça on verra ça va dépendre de
la forme de maxime aussi comment il
s'est vraiment remis ouais quand il
s'est vraiment remis quoi
de son élimination à l'oeil à la musique
excusez moi on s'est repris la musique
sur le truc elle ne devait pas être très
forte
maintenant tout ce qu'elle fait c'est ce
crime en simultané sur twitter et
youtube quoi exactement
mais moi je préfère twitch maintenant
quand ils m'ont dit de faire le
changement avec twitch youtube préféré
youtube est maintenant à force d'avoir
utilisé twitch je préfère twitch j'ai
pas vous si vous préférez tweets sur
youtube mais j'ai l'impression que déjà
il ya moins de latence et et je sais pas
non à une communauté plus cool sur
twitch généralement trouve pour les live
c'est plus adapté
après pour pour les vidéos c'est plutôt
youtube pour les vod mais pour les live
je trouve twitch vraiment mieux près
chacun ses goûts mais je préfère twitch
pour les live
donc donc donc donc j'aime bien ça crie
cas dans les stades quand même ouais
mais bon moi youtube on peut revenir en
arrière c'est vrai mais bon il ya plus
de latence ça va ça va sûrement partir
très bientôt
c'est déjà l'heure j'ai envie de dire et
on va pouvoir se lancer corps et âme
dans ce match salut à guy mauvaise one
alors nié toute demande plus de bande
passante ouais c'est plus proche du la
rive en fait c'est sûrement pour ça
est-ce que tu admires à nav est adopté
je crois plus je crois pas je crois
qu'elle avait réussi à faire neuf et
demi 1/2 ou des choses comme ça ouais je
suis d'accord monsieur pessoa moi aussi
j'ai l'impression que youtube est en
train de mourir en fait bizarrement il
ya de plus en plus de vue je pense est
de plus en plus de gens sur la
plateforme
mais pour moi youtube ça ressemble à un
réseau social fala sa réseau social blog
vidéo en perte de vitesse qu'on total et
j'ai l'impression que twitch est
vraiment en train de prendre le dessus
après on verra s'il n'y a pas de façon
c'est un peu ça les plates formes mince
a évolué mais c'est vrai que ça peut
aller très vite ainsi rappelé de myspace
avait disparu une vitesse incroyable et
et youtube je sais pas mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est c'est en train de
mourir après ludique moi j'ai un peu
parlé du concept jdg est fière de ce que
j'en pensais voilà ça va pas être on va
on va se lancer dans le match mais je
suis pas forcément à sa fin je suis 100%
d'accord sur la sur le fond mais pas sur
la forme en fait on va dire ça comme ça
le match qui démarre toujours pas
chanson qui cherche l'ouest les sauts
parce qu'il est inactif
ah ouais youtube c'est devenu un peu un
fourre tout et c'est devenu différent
youtube c'est c'est devenu un peu autre
chose alors le match pour le moment à ça
il vient de démarrer
ça y est on peut faire observer la
partie tranquille donc début du match
maxime avec les blancs donc on le voit
maxime vachier lagrave le joueur
français ici en dessous qui est un peu
un peu un peu grognon là quand même
visuellement wesley so de toute façon il
ya toujours l'air super heureux mais
maxime way cic que ça va être un match
difficile aujourd'hui pour pour situer
un peu le niveau de saut dans ces
compétitions l'année dernière il est
arrivé en finale il avait perdu contre
hikaru nakamura
dans un match très serré on vraiment ils
avaient ils avaient sorti il avait sorti
un gros match et et en embauchant tagnon
de 960 il ya un mois de ça il avait
battu en finale est devenu champion du
monde de 960 en battant magnus carlsen
en finale donc il peut il peut il peut
sortir des gros matchs sur sur les
événements qui choisit après là il n'a
pas été très bon au rapide et blitz de
bucarest
donc c'est un joueur j'ai envie de dire
un peu étonnant qui était monté jusqu'à
la deuxième place mondiale avant de
retomber un peu aux alentours de 27 60
27 70 donc c'est un joueur qui joue un
peu en dents de scie alors là cavalier
prendre cinq étaient jouables un pour
les blancs c'est une lente on avait déjà
vu avec fable mais ça donne du jour noir
avec le fou en fouillant kétou bien
placé et le fou qui pourrait venir un
jour en d6 donc le pion à pas été pris
hier cavaliers des quatre cavaliers d2
mais oui ouest et sow qui est un joueur
qui est pour moi assez énigmatique
capable capable du meilleur comme du
plus insipides je dirais je dirais pas
vraiment capable du meilleur comme du
pire que le pire c'est que faire des
nuls pour lui souvent mais il est
capable way de traverser des tournois il
est en train de ouais il est capable de
de passer des tournois comme une ombre
quoi où il fait nul sur un nul sans rien
faire c'est un peu étrange et puis j'ai
vu est parfois comme sur des speechs et
années 1960 ou même parfois on l'a vu
par le passé brillé dans des tournois en
partie longue surtout il ya deux trois
ans comme je le disais il et il est
capable d'un peu tout et on se demande
ce qui lui manque en fait pour avoir ce
déclic pour réussir à être le wesley so
précis pénible un peu un genre de
petrossian moderne qu'on peut connaître
parfois capable de mettre la pression
sur ses adversaires à la moindre erreur
et est finalement être un joueur de boa
constrictor vraiment à l'image d'un
petrossian c'est à dire rien lâcher
toujours toujours tenté un petit quelque
chose un petit avantage si l'adversaire
sera à trompe unis s'il se rate pas on
fait nul mais quand même avec cette
envie qui peut avoir parfois de mettre
ses adversaires en difficulté et
d'essayer de gagner en réalité alors que
comme comme je venais de le dire on voit
vraiment vraiment vraiment passé des
tournois entier même j'ai l'impression
des mois et des mois à être un wesley so
un boa constrictor du tout est juste un
bois bon j'entends dire un bois qui te
tombe dessus mais qui ne qui ne te la
serpe aqua fin juste un boa quoi enfin
un bon anormal boas sympa on aimerait
bien bien plus souvent le voir et on a
du mal à comprendre d'où vient le
problème de cette équation pour wesley
ensuite en ce qui concerne maxime va
vous le connaissez maxime numéro un
français maxime numéro quatre mondial
maxime qui rêve d'aller au tour on a des
candidats auxquels ils essayent
désespérément de se qualifier il lui
restera une balle de match à jérusalem
le tournoi commencera le 11 décembre que
ça bien évidemment commenté sur chef
point com fr et on sera curieux de voir
si maxime peut enfin accéder à son rêve
et à une qualification dans le très
prestigieux tour on a des candidats
alors cette partie pour le moment les
blancs ont une pièce de plus un pion de
plus par dont on joua dans le chat on
dit les cases noires un peu faible oui
mais encore un fou de cases noires donc
elle était sont elles si faible si on
réussit à faire foule échanger remettre
une dame en f2 ça ira bon après si on
fait tout pour en débattre ici pour se
débarrasser du problème du pion oui les
cases noires seront faibles parce qu'il
y aura plus le fou pour colmater donc à
voir par exemple sur fou prend qui on
prend on peut imaginer que les noirs
tente par la suite même des fous c'est
cette foulée 6 pour se remettre dans le
bon ordre après ce sera aux blancs d'où
ils auront un coût de répit on verra on
verra la pollution est compliqué donc
c'est ce qui fait est qu'un valet h 6
échecs alors l'idée sur pions prend ses
tours g4 et l'idée sur roy à schwyz et
cavaliers f50 maxime qui est en train de
puzzle rocher son adversaire dès la
première partie où le cavalier h6 là il
est vraiment beau de la part de maxime
ça c'est le genre de coups pas si dur
que ça a trouvé une fois qu on a l'idée
c'est très élégant mais c'est ouvert
qu'au top mondial
en tout cas en blitz en partie longue
c'est plus trouvable mais en blitz c'est
vraiment ouvert qu'aux meilleurs joueurs
du monde
ce cavalier h c'est ça qui fait vraiment
la différence 3 h 8 et cavaliers f5 qui
va rebondir et sur dame f6 lecavalier b3
qui protège la tour donc on peut prendre
en g3 donc il fait et j'ai h tours gk3
je suis tout reprend g3 mais maintenant
les cases noires il ya plus de problème
parce qu'il a plu le fouet les cases
blanches c'est blindé par les pions donc
maxime qui est un avantage probablement
décisif
son seul problème c'est cette tour g36
réussi à régler le problème de la tour
j'ai trois partout rejet 4 par exemple
ça ira mais ouais c'est qui va tout
donner là pendant quelques coups pour
essayer de
un genre de didier l'embrouillé wes lail
embrouille qui va tenter de mettre un
peu le bordel dans la position
tel un barbare on va voir on va voir
comment comment il a joué c mais la
maxime qui a valu à chis il a vraiment
trouvé une manière élégante de se
débarrasser de ce fou de cadres noirs
qui posait problème
alors comment est-ce qu'on joue côté
wesley saïd se fout on trouve peu de jeu
et ce qu'on essaye de faire food et 5
pour échanger et rentrer dans du final
avec les dames et les tours il fait
dames 5 or il gagne un tempo sur la tour
il veut aller prendre b2 j'imaginais un
dame veut un de la part de maxime
parce que c'est vrai que si la dame
réussi à venir un jour sur cette
diagonale ça peut faire mal mais wesley
qui a bien dû calculer dans on imagine
qu'il arrive à prendre b2 c'est un peu
la force de wesley il est très bon en
calcul et il est capable d'aller prendre
des pions comme ça même quand ça fait
peur ça fait quand même très peur parce
que là par exemple s'il y avait pas la
dame en b2i ojeda me cède j'attaque le
fou le foot bouche d'un même si ce match
tu vois donc c'est à dire que par
exemple un coup comme des gars tu crées
la menace d'armes 7 me serais juste à
temps pour faire tout 8
il a dû juger que c'était la seule le
seul moyen de tenter encore quelque
chose dans cette partie il a raison
parce qu'il rétablit l'équilibré
matériel ou est ce les os les solides
quand même la presse les qui qui qui
tente qui tente sa chance même même sous
la pression il se laisse pas mourir et
ils tentent de déstabiliser maxime ils
le forcent à trouver les coups alors qu'
on prend b5 jouait maintenant dame prend
ces deux on y croit moyen quand même
parce que cette diagonale à on semble ne
pas pouvoir la quitter donc on imagine
puis on prend b5 mais bon les pions
serait doublée saleh serait quand même
le pion des comme un vrai pion de plus
pour les blancs en réalité c'est vrai
que ça ça semble difficile surtout sur
ab tout reprend si on prend de la tour
on se dévierait la tour et si on prend
du fou il ya peut-être des dames 7 qui
commence à traîner très pénible puisque
la tour seraient touchés donc apprend b5
semble vraiment un bon coup peut-être
tour à 1,8 intermédiaire alors côté noir
pour
pas pour plus faire échanger les tours
et garder un peu de puissance de feu sur
sur la huitième rang j'ai donc tour à 8
semble peut-être être un coup logique on
nous dit sur dame français de dameuses
5c maddon après m6 dams est probablement
mais ça doit ça doit aller jusqu'au bout
mais de toute façon dame de france et
dont on n'y croit pas il a fait à 5 il a
fait à 5 alors j'aurais plutôt pensé à
tout et 8 mai à 5 ce qui se passe quoi
surfer juste tout reprend chez dams est
quand même maximy touche le fou donc le
fou va devoir partir ou pas est-ce qu'on
est obligé de le bouger ce fou alors sur
à quatre on attaque le cavalier m'aide à
me prends mes sept oncles ou ray le pion
avec la tour qui resterait en l'air donc
il semble que fout des cinq soit quasi
forcée et maxime qui ont peut-être joué
des quatre à ce moment là et peut-être
fallait vraiment joué tour à 8,1 parce
que des cats ce sera un problème il
menacera dab m6 donc wesley la décade ça
semble très fort je vois pas du tout
caler quelle est la défense pour les
noirs f6 si adam g7 matt tour à 6,6 adam
prend ensuite matt et donc ça gagne
tranquille le chat de wesley en sueur
maxime qui prend les devants
immédiatement dans ce match qui mène 1 0
ac qui n'a pas été bon faire le a5 raté
enfin ne pas faire le tour à 8 je
regarde sans ordi quand je mets le redis
je vous le dis donc tour à 8 pour éviter
un peu ses idées blanche ça semblait
être un peu le le seul coup pour prouver
qu'on existe mais mais ça peut être ai
je pour aux parois et cela alors maxime
qui jouent pas qui ne joue pas ça nage
dorff qui a décidé de jouer une taille
manoff donc il aussi capable de la jouer
c'est bon signe et mauvais signe à la
fois c'est bon signe parce qu'il garde
ses préparations et ses secrets pour
le grand prix fina à jérusalem qui est
bien entendu le l'événement principal de
sa saison maintenant c'est son objectif
principal il veut il faut aller aux
candidats après la mauvaise nouvelle
pour le match c'est qui va il va du coup
jouer des ouvertures qui connaît
peut-être un peu moins bien après en
blitz il faut dire que c'est pas
toujours ça qui fait la différence c'est
joueurs à ce niveau là ils connaissent
beaucoup de choses les deux sont à peu
près sur un pied d'égalité ils sortent
pas de nouveautés donc
ça et qui plus ou moins et ça peut aussi
ça peut aussi être intéressant de pour
maxime de tester un peu une autre
ouverture et de voir un peu ce que ça
pourrait donner c'est souvent assez
intéressant d'utiliser ces matches j'ai
envie d'appeler ça a des matches semi
amicaux parce que parce que l'enjeu
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas incroyable
mais d'un autre côté il ya quand même le
prestige d'argent et puis s'est jamais
vraiment amicale un match d'échecs comme
ça sur quatre heures
et c'est quand même assez intéressant de
servir de cette compétition pour pour
tester de nouvelles ouvertures et
éventuellement élargir son répertoire en
vue des candidats donc c'est voilà c'est
à mon avis une décision juste prise par
maxime donc de changer un petit peu ce
répertoire alors dam des trois à jouer
donc là l'idée évidemment dans cette
structure de pions qu'on retrouve aussi
dans les neiges dorff c'est pour les
blancs de contrôler la case des 5 est la
maxime il fait un truc intéressant il m
cavani angers 6 ils délaissent un petit
peu la casse des cinq en disant voilà tu
as mis tes deux cavaliers pour la
contrôler et moi maintenant je vais
essayer de jouer au tour en fait de
jouer à côté je vais te laisser la casse
des 5 et je vais jouer je vais jouer je
vais jouer sur le reste de l'échiquier
en réalité et on voulait probablement
pas jouer à 5 qui était proposée alors à
minima à cause de cavaliers prend 2,7
vous prendre cet écart valider cinq le
retour et ça faisait pas forcément pas
forcément intérêt mais après cavaliers
g6 et g3 on voit qu'ils jouent à cinq
maintenant puisque le cavalier ne peut
pas rester à faya plus l'idée de ramener
cavagnan des 5 kgs ses deux fours en d5
d'apprendre et s'inquiète anne decis et
maxime qui va pouvoir jouer pour
cavalier e set le retour qui touchera la
dame suivie de tour des huit des 5es ce
cavalier du coup ci passant de 3 on
n'hésitera pas une seule seconde on s'en
débarrassera et en k 2 h 4 on fera fou
h6 tranquillement quel meilleur des
dents bullet ses 107 maxime mais ce sera
très serré donc cavalier à trois
cavaliers sets joués par max qui s'en
prend à la dame
wesley qui va reculer j'imagine mais en
d3 comme ça il maintient une pression
sur b
5 est sur b4 il va revenir en c4 pour
s'en prendre aux pions des six on va
voir ce que maxime a préparés ici
puisque maintenant il ya une double
attaque une fourchette un quelque part
avec le pion des 6es la dame b6 et on va
voir si maxime peut s'en sortir s'il a
quelque chose en tout cas vu sa
réflexion il semble que il n'avait rien
prévu et qu'il espérait avoir quelque
chose de concluant ici dame ces cinq
heures d'un prandelli semble être un
vrai coup ici mais maxime qui va
peut-être chercher du con tre jeu par la
suite avec un prend prise prise en c3 et
ramener ensuite une tour en b2 pour
venir faire un petit peu du grabuge
alors ouais c'est qu'ils commencent par
h4 qui rejette le fou vers h6 mais
maintenant il va falloir se bouger alors
est-ce que wesley va prendre du cavalier
ou de la dame il prend de la dame
ça semblait être le plus logique
maintenant ça va échanger et on va voir
on va voir où ça nous ramène ça échange
en c3 et un coup comme tours b 2 va être
rencontrés probablement par fous ces
quatre pour venir contre attaques et
éventuellement sur le pion f7 donc
maxime ne laisse pas le cavalier en vie
mais cavalier peut revenir en c4 est
retouché une nouvelle fois un pion et
même deux pions car elle et ses 4
toucherait 2 pions donc c'est un peu les
scream là un lacet de l'escrim c'est un
cavalier escrimeurs j'ai envie de te
dire genre de laura flessel
il fait tour à b to c se trouvaient cinq
ans il défend tout et surtout rebellin
il veut faire tour c5 dont tour d un
jouet maintenant il veut s'approcher de
la 7e wesley
voilà c'est wes les shows il est chaud
wesley et peut-être maintenant jusqu'à
vallier prendre tout reprend tour
d'essai depuis poussé quatre et ça peut
être un genre de plan qui fait très mal
on va voir comment ça sa soeur
comment ça évolue mais ça peut être une
première idée ou de faire juste pour 17
d'ailleurs direct jean retour 17
cavaliers ces quatre prises c4 mais
peut-être tour c5 un peu embêtant foulée
trois tours pensée trois tours d un ce
serait un avantage mais la maxime aurait
quand même récupérer pions ou est ce les
qui va vouloir faire mieux alors faire
mieux pour ou ac c'est peut-être à
quatre roues est exactement et surtour
b3 venir prend
retour prend et mettre le fou en b cinq
histoires et non il prend à 5 prend deux
prises ces trois encore plus fort pardon
je me suis mélangé maintenant le feu
arrive en bessin qu'avec un pion à qui
semble très fort surtout que le x h 6 il
est un petit peu silencieux il est mis
mis au ban de la société ici le fois ci
ce qui va pouvoir manifester son
mécontentement mais qui va peut-être pas
être écoutés par par les autres pièces
puisque les pièces blanches ont quand
même mis les barbelés pour l'empêcher
d'arriver et de revenir éventuellement
sur la case c5 qui serait une case qui
fait plaisir puisqu'il attaquerez f2 et
maxime qui voyant que le pion à filer à
dame abandonne wesley so après un début
de match difficile il est pas rentré
dedans dans la première mais une
deuxième partie menée de main de maître
par le chas américain le chat américain
qui qui égalise tout de suite et on part
maintenant sur un gambit dame bien joué
de la part de wesley qui qui mène qui
mène une belle partie et qui a encaissé
les pions mais donc maxime qui joue un
système qu en un système colle avec le
fou en b2 vers la structure de pions et
on va trouver peut-être des pions
pendant voir un pion isolé et peut-être
des pions pendant ici avec le fou en b2
bien placé pour les éventuelles
ouvertures à base de dessins etc si les
plans prenez en d5 et prend des cinq on
créerait le pion isolé et pour ceux qui
ont suivi l'excellente série de vidéos
qu'on a fait avec la tcat chef cette
fois fils qui a eu 7 est une idée mais
ici aurait peut-être dû vous prend h 7
échecs dames ces deux dames français 6
donc sur ces prend des cinq peut-être
que les noirs au prix de la dame alors
lucas et ses trois poupées 7
développement tour un tour c'est 8 pour
le moment la structure de pions n'est
pas encore défini au centre d'essai puis
on prend qui est des cats n'est jamais
une menace parce qu'il ya des fourrages
cet échec à la fin tour c'est un protège
g6 pour couvrir cette diagonale ça peut
être intéressant fouet fin parce que le
pion décade pouvait être fragilisé par
les dames prend des 4 enfin de pariente
tour 8 émanant wesley veut faire flouer
fuite fou g7 avec l'idée de venir taper
le pion des quatre qui est voué à être
faible
3 et vite peut-être des cavaliers g4
mais fou à l'affût de fou g7 et les
noirs sans leur une position assez assez
intéressante assez solide avec
éventuellement des faiblesses pour les
blancs mais cavalier e 5 maxime frappe
tout de suite
sur ces six peut-être avec des idées de
prises et du jeu sur sur cette case
peut-être un jour un fou qui jaillit en
assistant certaines variantes
ça peut être intéressant genre fou g7
puis on prend admettons cavaliers prend
cavaliers prend fou prend fou à 6 pour
toucher sa tour ici cavaliers b5 peut
être le genre de variantes jouable même
si on aurait préféré avoir dû pousser 4
il faut virer 7 comprend cavaliers prend
c'est ce que vous avez expliqué bon
laquelle c'est si ce n'était pas si fort
mais commence par 44 il peut préparer un
jour des problèmes donc on a la
structure du pion isoler les noirs qui
peuvent mettre en place le cavalier ce7
qui est un super une super mains pour
tenir le pion et repartir peut-être vers
f5
comme je lé dispositif vidéo avec vlad
on a en a fait un travail assez un assez
long sur cette structure de pions mais
là peut-être maxime veut jouer avec fois
à troyes pour pour toucher la case des
six en tout cas la partie et est
intéressante est pour le moment bien
mené de la part des deux joueurs et
salut à tayrac dans le tchat
alors comment est-ce que ça a continué
fff qui prend une décision très
responsable il chasse le cavalier
cavaliers ces six touches la dame
il imagine plutôt tour prend puisque
fougue et cinq rencontres tours france
est un
ça gagne pas de qualité sur
sur les changes des f-5 c'est vraiment
très radicale parce que ça affaiblit
aussi ce pion mais il veut sûrement joué
avec des cavaliers qui arrive en f4 la
dame angers 5
le vis-à-vis peut être désagréable plus
vrai si fait cavalier qu'adam g 5 pour
des 8
mais bon il y aura g3 le fou et bien
pépère mais perd le chat le roi qui
pourrait être bien défendu une position
très déséquilibré car lycées qu'adam g 5
pas décrier dans le sens compliqué et
peut-être g3 et sur quoi peut-être tour
des huit truc c'est que dame chez synck
menaces cavalli prend h3 à l'idée de g3
c'est juste de défendre là et là aussi
mais ça semble pas marcher cavaliers
prend h3 peut être un coup aussi
d'ailleurs
puis on prend dame échec rouages de
dames f4 3g un mais on n'a probablement
pas mieux perpète
il a fait d'amd 5 à une menace cavaliers
prend h 3 puis on prend et d'un machin
matt donc f3 pour tout couvrir et tour
des huit
j'aime beaucoup ce coup dam des saints
qui a bien été trouvé et et c'est vrai
que le pion des cats le pion isolant des
4es et une vraie faiblesse et sur cave a
lieu cinq le problème c'est qu'il faut
prendre 5 pour prendre cinq dames prend
2,5 puis on prend cinq tours prend des
seins qui gagnerait qui gagnerait le
pion donc le pion des quatre en sueur il
n'est pas défendable cavaliers 3 il ya
fou prend des quatre qui vous sur le
couloir et il va falloir que maxime
trouve une manière de bien donner le
pion alors il a encore trois minutes 28
à la pendule
donc il a le temps donc on va voir on va
voir on va voir
on va voir
alors le pion des quatre en difficulté
pour voir comment il fait mais je sais
pas je pense que c'est mauvais mais
c'était très bien joué là si on revient
aux rétrospectives
le g6 fou g7 pour mettre la pression sur
des 4 et après jouer sur le pur isolée
c'était vraiment vraiment une bonne
partie du reste c'est donc un vrai lieu
de trois on imagine fou prend des quatre
maintenant vous prend des katas me
prends des caprices des cas de prise des
gâtés maxime qui va tenter de défendre
cette finale aurait peut-être défendable
parce que tour c1 il veut rentrer sur
tour des six ya cavaliers c4 qui est
assez important puisqu'il toucherait la
tour il pourrait revenir en 5
ouais c'est plutôt bien alors fou et 8
peut-être pour wesley va être joué avec
l'idée sur tours c'est celle de jouer
tour 17
alors tour des six cavaliers c4 et il
doit avoir une idée maintenant tour des
cinq cavaliers prend b6 à béton français
si c'est quoi le délire de wesley il
veut faire préfère tourner je suis un
peu étonné un parent par le jeu doit
c'est là j'ai regardé alors 10 et 6 6 1
enfouie 8 est numéro 1 d'ailleurs j'ai
l'impression que maxime est mieux ici
bas tant mieux écouter il ya le fouet
fin qui attaquent le pion b5
c'est un craquage tour des six lycées 4
il a gaffé ouais il a gaffé wesley et
maxime qui va pouvoir jouer la gagne
dans cette finale est ce qu'elle vous
rappelle quelque chose cette finale avec
le rapport au matériel fou cavaliers et
puis on passait à est ce que ça vous ça
vous dit quelque chose ou pas du tout
alors une idée ou pas rich aucoin
c'est ce que maxime va essayer de faire
donc il va avoir un pion pas c b le
cavalier qui est loin du jeu et il va
essayer de faire avancer ce pion on
verra on verra ce que ça donne
donc j'ai quatre cavaliers g3 il veut
juste faire [ __ ] en bessin qu'en
réalité
ouais non ça va là pour maxime n'ya
aucun aucun soucier tous les feux sont
au vert côté français et c'est une
partie qui va faire mal et sur f4
attention paroisse e4 qui paraîtrait
logique à cause de cavale et g3 mais
trois des quatre plus tôt et on va venir
tout encaisser ou ac qui est dans le dur
1 kg 3e 5 dont il tente le va-tout en
envoyant les pions ça peut être en
brouillant parce que lecavalier ça peut
faire des échecs ça peut faire des
fourchettes c'est pas si simple agagner
mais
mais bon il faut qu'ils renient fischer
time and off
ouais ça ressemble encore plus
afficheurs time and of limbs ont bien vu
mais bon je ne m'attendais pas à une
telle culture générale dans le chat puis
on prend en plus on prend on va voir
pour ses 5
alors maintenant le jeu cf 4 et 4
probablement un pour envoyer le pion et
tour de assez bien joué tour de la part
de wesley raté par maxime le food
intervient plus sur la case de 2 il veut
faire tour trois tours f3000 embrouillé
avec son cavalier g3 savait que le
problème c'est que le pion de maxime est
loin où celle ci protège mais peut-être
maintenant eux quatre ça va peut-être
quatre où peut-être va faire tour trois
rois c4e quatre pions prend des f3 je
vois bien ouais c'est faire un truc
comme ça
et le fou était très bien placé en b 5
mais il a dû se déplacer
roy g7 bk tour trois rois c4 et
peut-être eu quatre maintenant qu'elle
prend 1,4
quel point je pensais que voulait faire
f 3 alors qu'elle prend 1,4 mais là il
n'y a pas qu'à cavaliers des 2 3 des 5
j'avais vu qu'il y ait des 2 3 des 4 et
les cavaliers
cavaillé nulle part d'ailleurs position
il vraiment compliqué tour ces trois
échecs à temps ses trois échecs c'est
encore une autre tactique ou la lie en
art il ya beaucoup de tactique de
partout des enfilades tout reprend
maxime qui peut prendre du roi tous
rêvent à et tour c4 qui va faire un nul
et surtout reprendre 4 f3 fait b5
intermédiaire au roi
alors là c'est chaud bouillant là c'est
chaud bouillant est-ce qui va faire
tourner ses cinq tours c5 paraître un
coup dans ces 5 semble être un coût pour
les noirs je m l'ordi pour voir la tour
c 5 tout réussi soit étouffée nul en
fait
mais tous ces 500 lettres un couteau
reprend 1,4 reprend b5 tourcoing f4 et
c'est nul
j'ai envie de dire nulles de combat les
deux joueurs ont eu leur moment les deux
joueurs ont fait des fautes et ça ça
finit par là nul et surtout ses 53.4 et
tout reprend 1,5 roi prend 1,5 et f3
c'était très tactique une très belle
partie et sai et maxime est parti dans
la neige d'or je vous ai dit à ses
matches ça reste amical cinq minutes et
puis après ça ça ça commence à envoyer
parce que les deux hommes ont vraiment
envie de gagner alors ils vont pas à
jouer leur prépa les warrants numéro 1
mais ils vont jouer ce qu'ils peuvent
jouer et ça ça envoie forcément tu as
envie de ta envie de gagner donc là on
voit une variante avec un f4 rapide qui
17 donc toujours cette histoire de cases
de gaz des 5 es là l'idée du f4 c'est
que quand on prend il veut prendre du
fou pour venir tout de suite ciblé le
pion des six est pas une manière de
jouer que j'ai souvent vu dans les
parties que je regarde de jouer avec 4,4
même si je
le connais pas je sais que c'est
possible de jouer avec 4,4 contre cette
structure mais dans ce cas précis j'ai
pas l'impression que j'ai déjà vu deux
parties après je vois pas non plus
toutes les parties je me rappelle pas de
tout bien heureusement alors fou 3 alors
elle surfe ou g7 le problème c'est qu'il
ya tam francs d'ici ça c'est un vrai
problème donc le fou vient aux 7es
est-ce que puis on prend 1,5 et fouache
6 est jouable ou f5 et fois ci soit même
plus tôt possible on va voir ce que ça
donne ça vexe fois à chis pour être
juste chasse et parfois fuite fawcett
mais attention sur x figurez vous prend
et aidé à me prendre et 6 comme cette
fois ci c'est un coup ici laissez le
pion le 4 pour les blancs est ce une
idée on va voir ce que maxime peut pas
jouer fois fitia fou prend aidé à me
prendre et 6 1 bon mais on peut
peut-être le faire en deux temps leur
foi justice bouger le cavalier et
ensuite faire foi fuite
on va voir alors comment ça évolue d'amd
3 way sli qui touche la tour b 5 qui la
protège casse des cinq qui est quand
même bien contrôlé par maxime ainsi à
quelque chose qui jaillit sur des cinq
on pourra échanger et remettre l'autre
en f 6 et sur x 6 way or l europe qui
serait impossible
il l'a fait à quatre et il s'en prend
aux pions b5 du coup ils jouent
complètement à la dame
et c'est vrai qu'il pose un vrai
problème une vraie question à maxime
parce que sur fion prend et adam
français 4 et sûr aux caprices b5 prise
b5 prise b5 et il va s'en prendre à la
tour et aux pions des six mais maxime
pourra faire tout reprendre 4 fr puis on
prend qui on prend cavaliers prendre ton
prend 2,4 ça a l'air d'être quand même
une variante
e très critique compliqué alors soit je
sois put on a pu voir d'un v6 pour
protéger pour protéger le pion des six
effectivement il y avait tout un tas de
coin mais là du coup qu'elle prend b5
pas faisable
peut-être il fait qui a régné à 5 en
premier donc l'idée doit s l'eso est
clair il veut prendre en b 5 sur tourbe
et 4 pour maintenir le suspense est
contrôlé avec cavaliers c6 qui menacent
et toulon tours b 8 tours c8 été forcée
et qui a rallié prend b5 maintenant
jouer et ça me semble très bien pour eux
et c'est malheureusement
menacée cavaler bessette donc avait
laissé cinq bien joué mais fou prend ses
cinq ya pas tout repenser 5 à cause de
kébé cette fourchette maxime obligés de
prendre du pillon et la minima a pas
forcément à minima parce que le pion le
cadre peut rester en l'air mais il ya
peut-être des trucs qui a valu à cette
cavale et c6 qui peuvent rodez il fait
cavalier c4 a énoncé moche c'est moche
c'est moche sur dame prend ya pions
prend qui tient tout est dans l'autre
cas de figure le cavalier vraiment très
fort ici peut même faire juste d'amd 8
qui a laissé 3 way sli et le cavalier c4
défend b2 il protège tous ils attaquent
donc non non c'est assez assez laid
comme position c'est assez laid pour
maxime
alors après il peut encore il peut
encore s'en sortir mais c'est un peu là
à l'arrêt ce prix ce prix des cahiers c3
probablement il tient à eux quatre il
tient ici sur tourbe et qu'at-il va
faire b3 ce cavalier indélogeable ci lui
vient pour déloger il ya lui qui vient
ici pour attaquer il ya de la torah 7
qui rôde il ya de la whey il ya de tout
il ya le cavalier qui peut être fragile
hausse parce que quand on prend on
découvre c'est une catastrophe maxime
qui va être mené au score et ça fait mal
hein ça fait mal parce que wesley semble
semble vraiment vraiment forme ce soir
salut mario dans le chatt difficile 1
alors il fait tour des quatre mairies
qui prend 1,5
ouais il prend mais là dessus j'ai peur
qu'ils aient des problèmes avec
bon allez c'est jeu de maxime accueilli
6,6 souhaite bien jouer et à cailhau cet
échec croyez fut ton corps mais caraïbes
et cinq noms rouaroua de 7
c'est pas juste une pièce
ouais c'est juste une pièce mais il veut
peut-être fait retour des 2 max mais il
y aura cavaliers 3 qui défendra tout je
pensais que les fairways fuite mais il y
avait d'autres problèmes probablement et
là il n'y a rien il prend 1,4 alors il
tente un peu d'embrouillés maxime mais
objectivement la position est perdante
on avait vu en plus wesley contre magnus
capable d'une précision vraiment
remarquable qui défend l'aïe soit il
transforme un cavalier f5 wesley mais
c'est pas ce que j'aurais fait soit on
maxime qui se bat bien bas il va
transformer pour prendre des quatre et
il veut transformer là dedans il a dû
calculé qu'après tour d'éric gagné le
pion j'imagine ouais il a dû calculer un
peu plus loin et il a vu que maxime
pouvait pas sauver deux pions des 4 et
donc tu auras tout reprendre des quatre
au prochain et et tour g4 par la suite
le jour où le cavalier s'en va et maxime
qui est qui en grosse difficulté mais
c'est vrai que ouais c'est assez assez
domine en ce début de match il faut le
dire tiens les g3 alors il s'en prend à
la tour et surtour f3 et ce qu'il a une
idée notre maxime il veut faire cavalier
f5 g4 et cavaliers h4rem et l'option va
quand même finir par tomber
mais c'est vrai que c'est ça semble
offrir de meilleures chances donc wac
s'est fait autour des 3 il a le temps de
le prendre le cavalier en diagonale h5
hockey j'aime bien ce que fait maxime
quand même un pur pour résister il
réussit à mettre en place un
genre papa de forteresse mais quelque
chose de solide va pouvoir peut-être
faire du roi g5 venir un peu taquiné
tour f3 il fera tours 5
et il a une position encore peut-être te
nabeul en tout cas ça va demander des
efforts pour pour la gagner pour wesley
a laissé bien maxime ça peut partir de
là roi g5 qui défend bien tour f3 donc
là on imagine tours 5
pour tout défendre fait cavalier h4
alors là ça tient sur sur le fil du
rasoir tour f2 ce qui va faire tourner
un échec
il prend prend et cavaliers f5 s est
malin il va essayer d'allonger c'est le
pion il veut h4 est roi pro f 6 maxime
hausse est tellement bien joué de la
part de du joueur français
bref un droit prend pas possible âgées
4000 va commencer par h4 et il va
réussir à s'emparer du pion avec un
cavalier qui tiendra tout il va falloir
il va falloir mettre les barbelés mais
peut-être qu'on peut on peut et on peut
espérer une partie nulle donc h4 jouer
roi deux rois des trois mois il fait
tour f4 avant et tours j'ai quatre
points d'accord pourquoi pas alors il va
vouloir quoi il va falloir mettre un
joueur de zoug besoin ou assez pour
faire entrer le roi e4 et sur wade 5 3 5
qui vont il ya peut-être des idées on va
voir là il va faire froid des trois
cavaliers f5
mais on voit pas trop comment le joueur
américain peut progresser pour le moment
et il va peut-être faire tourner 8 ici
pour essayer de couper le roi mais où
est ce qu'il veut en venir à nantes où
rêvent qu'à 3 e 5 tours gk3 des cinq on
voit pas trop où il veut en venir pour
le moment l'américain suroît f67 qui
veut tout reprend des 4 encore que
il veut peut-être tour 4 coupé et voir
alors cavaliers ou 3 il ya quelque chose
qui m'a échappé sur wade cinq jeux met
un petit coup d'ordi cette tour 4
maintenant et à roye des six trois c4
peut-être est bon maxime qui fait
cavalier e 3 bon c'est intéressant aussi
parce que l'idée c'est surtout râches
quatre cavaliers j'ai deux tours des
quatre cavaliers avec quatre échecs mais
ouais c'est qui va sûrement faire tour
quatre intermédiaires roi f5 et roy
prend des 4 mai maxime qui a réussi à
liquider des pions elle doit tenir celle
là quand même à mon avis à mon avis elle
doit tenir doit pouvoir tenir
peut-être m le cavalier tf cinq là
attention f5 aller c est d'un peu tout
bloquer a mené tête le cavalier vers eux
quatre il ya des cavaliers g2 aussi qui
rôde il va la tenir
ouais c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle un
ce que la partie était mal engagée
tourache américaine g2a et attention
qualifié de yves leroy au 5 et pointe
qu'à trois f4 double angle on croit g4
jouer bien jouer maxime allais faut la
tenir
courage de on sait pas trop pourquoi il
peut peut-être faire rager 3 d'ailleurs
à l'émotion éviter kg 2 il peut faire
rager 3 / h 5 ha il pouvait prendre il
revient allez vous le faire tomber
faire tomber wesley pour katia cavaliers
g3 à lewes est là il va devoir y va les
prendre il va il va courir prendre
l'option et ça c'est nul facile ou ac
qui va un peu la jouer en bide c'est
normal non même pas respect respect
mutuel il l'attend pas il fait nul tout
de suite aller ça fait 2-2 chez joueurs
ont eu leurs chances respectives
maxime qui a sorti une défense dont il a
le secret et il réussit à égaliser
immédiatement donc maintenant une c4 une
anglaise ces cinq anglais symétrique et
g3 maxime qui veut mettre son fou en
fouillant quête au cimetière vraiment
sorti une une défense de fer on voit là
que les que que le niveau de jeu est
quand même assez élevé de la part des
deux hommes
c'est un beau match en espérant que ça
remette vraiment maxime en confiance au
vu des échéances qui l'attendent en
décembre on vous rappelle du 11 au 23
décembre
le gp jérusalem qui sera pour maxime
déterminant dans sa dans son éventuelle
qualification pour le tournoi des
candidats donc à l'élu h 4 h 5 qui se
déroulera à lesquin terrain bourgue je
crois du 15 mars au 5 avril prochain
donc non vraiment c'est un beau début de
match qui semble prudent c'est dur de
mettre un joueur devant on a chaque
joueur a eu ses périodes dans ces
parties maxime qui a été plus robuste en
défense comme fischer glisse pas sûr que
my name veille soit plus forts en bulles
à doigts et c'est loin d'être sûr c'est
loin d'être sûr en plus c'est dur 1 + 1
on a vraiment du mal à savoir qui sera
qui sera le meilleur là dans le bullet
on se rappelle d'un gros match de wesley
la saison dernière en finale en bullet
notamment contre icare où il avait
résisté beaucoup mieux qu'on ne l'avait
imaginé des dames à 5 est arrivé 6 et en
trois et ce qui est plus fort mais je
pense que c'est équilibré dans tout les
cas dans 6 6 1 je vois pas d'un des deux
joueurs sur le papier plus favori dans
une cadence que l'autre pour moi c'est
vraiment des joueurs à peu près du même
niveau après comme j'utilisais jeu peut
étonner que l'algorithme des noës les
favoris à la vue de ses performances que
ce soit l'année dernière en
en speechless où il arrivait quand même
en finale et où que ce soit en
championnat du monde 960 donc c'est vrai
qu'il a montré des belles qualités
wesley et c'est pas étonnant alors là on
a une structure de pions assez marrante
on pourra avoir un losange centrale ce
qui est quand même assez rare et j'aime
plutôt bien la position des noirs dans
le sens où le roi blank par un peu
faible mais d'un autre côté ses
positions fermes et cavaliers contrefous
c'est compliqué il ya des pions doublé
d'un autre côté si les blancs peuvent
faire à troyes b 4 peut être un jour va
savoir ce que ça peut donner
mais le losange est mis en place il va
vouloir envoyer fc un k-way cela il doit
il doit jouer sur sur cet amas de pion
central s'arrête c'est rare de voir un
losange mais on en a alors faire ça hiva
et hiva rockets f3 le fou qui va
repartir peut-être en dix-sept pouvoir
peut-être touché 1 4 dans il part en os
6 et il fait f5
je pense pas que maxime est grand
intérêt à faire baisser décès il va
juste échangé des six qui est pas très
utile donc il va probablement plutôt
essayer de jouer sur une majorité de
pions mais là attention aux idées avec
qui on prend qui on prend fouache trois
rois f2 peuvent avoir des pourpoints f3
roi prend et tour f8 donc maxime qui met
le cavalier à angers un protecteur des
cases blanches dans cette position est
sûre pions prend il reprendra de f
et il viendra échanger le long de la
colonne f
c'est peut-être jouable
maxime laquelle vient c'est bien joué et
couvre les cases et il va vouloir
envoyer du tour b 1b 5 peut-être un jour
dans un lointain futur dans une
lointaine galaxie
ils auraient éventuellement cette idée
presque ouest et à faire rage cette fois
justice pour échanger le mauvais fou
contre le bon fou c'est un peu long puis
se fout et peut-être pas si mauvais
peut-être fouet f6 du coup meilleur s'il
avait cette idée qu'est ce qui peut nous
faire d'autre
gagner le plan b cas depuis tu alors on
peut pas vraiment un pic à 6 en l'air à
la fin mais peut-être qu'il peut
réfléchir à ce genre de variantes avec
une tour seul et essayer d'aller jouer
pour la colonne b ça peut être une
éventualité
et c'est justement l'éventualité qui
retient dans la partie et il joue plutôt
dame b cette menace la tour et menaces
tour b2 donc il semble que tour à deux
soit le seul coup
donc on est six tours b 2 à maxime qui
veulent dame prend b2 dame prend b2 tour
deux dames b1 tout aussi ce dam des
trois ça semble un peu dégueu ça semble
un peu dégueu il ya quoi matériellement
faut toujours compter il ya pour
cavaliers contre dame puisque le pion
disparaît
angers 6 que maxime va encore nous faire
une défense dont il a le secret on va
voir ça puis on prend d'un prince et
quatre sur fouache 6e pierroise 7 pour
les noirs
ça n'a pas fonctionné le pion des faits
peur donc maxime qui vient se mettre
tout de suite devant et sur detroit il
veut probablement tour 3 pour colmater
alors comment est-ce que wesley va
progresser ici c'est toute la question
qu'on se pose y fait damer 7 à il veut
faire dame f1 et tous rêvent de très
bien jouer ce coup de replacements là
c'est pas des coups très difficile à
faire de la difficulté c d enchaîner un
et on peut pas couvrir les trois cases
mangou
une 2e on ne peut pas couvrir la
troisième surtout il ya dame f2 surtout
rêve de iliad à me prendre donc on peut
pas couvrir cette colonne f côté côté
français c'est tour des huit pour pour
échanger une tour il ya dame f1 qui
arrive direct en premier lieu avec un
grand danger je pense que west et va la
gagner celle-là il va falloir serrer le
jeu côté côté maxime
il avait déjà été en difficulté en début
de match contre oui avant de se
réveiller et de finalement écrasé le
joueur chinois
il va falloir réaliser une performance
du même acabit
parce qu'on a en face de nous un wesley
so en grande forme le ch a sorti sa
crinière
allez va falloir il va falloir faire mal
avec la avec la nage dorff maintenant il
va falloir entrer les points ou en tout
cas et arrêter l'hémorragie avec la nage
dorff il faut pas laisser ou est ce les
soa plus à plus de +3 on va essayer
quand même de le garder en respect donc
puisqu'on vous expliquer tout à l'heure
c'est que sur les fourrages 6 on
pourrait faire d'un bep six échecs et
fouet fit adam protégerait le pion donc
là c'est enchaîner ça a joué tout tempo
il ya eu un changement quelque part
honnêtement j'ai pas vu ou c'est aller
trop vite
c'est je pense c'est maxime qui a changé
le destin de la partie en prenant f5 en
tout cas les deux joueurs qui ont
enchaîné les coups est ce que les
caméras sont un directeur on a un petit
délai de quelques secondes mais c'est du
quasi direct on voit maxime qui boissons
jus de pomme aller il va falloir fermer
les portes
évidemment on pourrait dans un match
aussi serré que ça avec des joueurs de
même niveau on peut même remonter 1 - 3
- 4 1 c'est pas c'est pas comme dans
dédé des matches comme celui qu'on a vu
hier on santé car des deux joueurs était
était vraiment plus fort
lassé des joueurs du même niveau ça peut
aller très vite abandonnant bullet sur
un rush un petit coup de fatigue et tu
peux tu peux faire trois défaites d'un
côté comme de l'autre un d'ailleurs mais
quand même il faut pas laisser
joueur s'échapper et wesley qui peut
être très dangereux on l'avait vu contre
magnus 1 quand il prend le contrôle d'un
match après il est pénible à déboulonner
c'est un peu comme c'est un peu comme en
irlande et dans un rack une fois qu'il a
mis les mains sur le ballon il est
pénible à déblayer faut pas le laisser
traîner il va pas il va pas falloir
laisser le joueur américain prendre ses
aises dans ce match il va falloir faire
comme tout à l'heure et tout de suite
recoller maxime qui fait bouger 5
il veut échanger les fous et surfe où
pranger cinq prises j'ai cinq à six il
peut peut-être même aller chercher ces
deux ou pas mais bon même même rocroi
jeu suit et tours j'ai 800 possible le
joueur américain qui gardent les fous
sur l'échiquier et la tour qui vient en
g8 donc maxime qui garde son roi au
centre mais c4 arrive j'aime bien la
position des plans une nouvelle fois
tams et 8 menace le pion et menace le
fur a laissé une petite double attaque
pour max mais ces 5 et bien joué il veut
il veut il veut affaiblir 5% prendre au
roi noir
il est pénible il est pénible c'est dans
ce match il est pénible alors dame prend
f5
puis on prend fut f4 aller max qui crée
peut-être des menaces avec du dame prend
h3 damage de maths en idées et qui coupe
la colonne est fait qui protège le pion
à eux aller ça c'est bien joué de la
part du joueur français qui doit qui
doit qui doit montrer l'étendue de son
talent dans cette partie et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il est en train de
faire ce que dame prend h3c une vraie
menace est ce que wesley va juste se
décale avec le roi allait en h1 il alla
d'amendé cinq bien placé il peut se
permettre de faire un petit coup comme
ça deroy h 1 c'est ce qui fait défend le
pion h3 puisque le pion gêner plus floue
et maintenant et la dame qui a du mal à
intervenir sur un jeu surtout que même
comme fou j'ai un pot est possible
maintenant pour les blancs avec flash de
une petite manoeuvre qui paye pas de
mine mais qui pourrait être pénible roi
17 le joueur français qui s'en prend un
peu aux pions des six mais pour le
moment il y avait cette emprise donc fou
g1 est une option côté côté américain ou
même fou et trois peut-être avec la même
idée sauf qu'elle est plus direct
puisqu'on gagne un tempo donc fou prend
f4 menace maintenant puisque même 3 f 4
puisque sur fion prend il ya un clouage
et surtout reprend des systèmes prend
bessette fait mal maxime qui ajouté à me
6 et qui va rentrer dans cette finale et
il a juste à temps pour faire tourner
cette le pion des six lui appartient et
maxime qui va pouvoir aller chercher là
nul tranquillement dans cette partie et
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
allez il va falloir maintenant avec les
pièces blanches à la prochaine réussir à
inquiéter le joueur américain
prenons le problème c'est un petit peu
comme un parti longue pour maxime
le problème pour maxime c'est pas les
pièces noires avec les noirs il est il
est solide redoutable mais avec avec les
pièces blanches il a du mal à mettre à
mettre ses adversaires sur le reculoir
il a du mal et on nous dise haut et
super fort surtout en partie sur
internet et plus femme était numéro 2
mondial a donc et il est champion du
monde de 960 donc il était peut-être un
peu plus que simplement en partie sur
internet champion du monde c'est quand
même j'ai quand même un titre assez
sympa à voir à son palmarès le roi blanc
en train de lire le journal c'est pas
faux mais le roi blanc elle va pouvoir
courir ou pas tour ses huit bien joué il
veut mettre la tour en c2 maxime qui
sont là ont pris le parti de un petit
peu pressés à la rentrée peut peut-être
faire moi j'ai deux tours ces deux et
tous rêvent de et colmater sa deuxième
rangée
cependant il peut pas faire wave 3 où il
peut peut-être mais peut-être pour ces
deux ans maxime qui comme souvent à
après avoir égalisé continue
il veut mettre la pression à leur tour
prend b2 tout reprend h7
ça va être tendu ducale sont alors
tournés cet échec qui veut dévier le roi
pour gagner la case de 4,3 six tours
prend tout reprend à deux alors qui est
mieux ici personne non roi à 4 tours
échec tout reprend h trois tours b si
c'est ça échange partout sans que ça
fasse nul en moi il a pensé à moi j'ai
deux mais au pire y avait des échecs
enfin maxime qui va faire nul et c'est
chose faite donc maxime qui récupère les
pièces blanches
il refait c4as que wesley va continuer
avec ses 5
oui il continue car il ya trois
cavaliers ap six cavaliers ces trois
cavaliers c6 mais j'ai trois dons qui re
il rejoue l'anglais symétrique des cinq
jouer des quatre fonctions quasi
symétriques
sauf que les blancs ont joué chez trois
prises des caprices des caprices et 4 le
fou g2 qui va être une belle pièce et on
rentre dans cette finale qui est un peu
mieux pour les blancs mais ça doit pas
être gravissime pour les noirs le pion
sait si c'est un poil faible mais les
noirs qui peuvent s'organiser pour le
défendre
cependant tu position un peu plus
agréable pour les blancs il va falloir
que maxime réussissent à mettre la
pression donc
cavalier e 3 mais lorsqu'il prend ces
quatre voir ce que ça va on est six ans
pour le moment m et c'est pas mal parce
qu'on n'a pas de pas de premières pages
jusqu'ici donc c'est plutôt on est
plutôt dans une bonne moyenne en nombre
de spectateurs donc fou des 5 fu d2 il
va il va il faut qu'il faut aller
récupérer le pion avec du tour c'est un
fake faux ici c'était bien joué il n'a
pas laissé à maxime le temps de
récupérer ces quatre c3 alors est ce
qu'il peut faire est prise quel est ce
un raid en saut qui précis qui va qui va
réussir à avoir un truc juste égal une
nouvelle fois et on n'a pas avec les
blancs quelconque avantage en fou aux
cinq ça touche la tour heureusement
sinon au relief 6 e 5 et sur 4 km et 4
qui est pénible et qui va retoucher la
case d3 le nom pad même même c'est pas
wesley finalement qui est bien ici
cavalli ou trois peut-être si si si
maman et e5 est vrai ce qui va louer
pouces et 3 forcé bon après un prix de 3
et de 5 à exactement
et c'est pénible il ya quand même un
pion plus pour le moment en vie et la
tour en bessette est pas si mal placé
puisque du coup quand on fera tourner
vite on gagne un temps en réalité way
une nouvelle fois maxime avec les blancs
qui réussit pas à faire mal c'est un
vrai problème
alors b3 l'idée c'est que sur pions
prend puis on prend pour prendre il
faudra prendre un set
une nouvelle fois un maxime qui est bon
qui est un très bon défenseur et la tour
c'est un bien jouer qui on prend pions
prend et il continue la pression
là-dessus il y aura peut-être tour
bessette
il va peut-être s'organiser wesley alors
il fait tourbe et 8
il veut la jouer ses pions prend tour b2
et peut-être tour d un tour des 3 au
tour ces trois arrêts pour faire tout re
tour qui vient et il fait tour à trois
ça c'est encore une autre idée
maxime qui va chercher de la géométrie
qui va chercher du placement thiès
attention de pas se prendre sur tours d
un e 4 un moment donné qui enfermerait
un peu le roi en f2 et qui contrôlerait
la case d3 pour éviter les rebonds de la
tour vers des 6es vers détroit et 17
peut-être quatre ici un coup pénible je
vais mettre un petit coup d'ordi ça me
parait pénible il a fait tousser devrait
n'en sais encore plus fort pour mission
est pénible à jouer tant que 4,5 g ici
c'est le roi cette sphère jkd vite un
niveau il pourra jouer avec tours b2g
cinq ans fermé ce roi c'est c'est
dangereux la côte et blanc
donc bon là pour julie jus dans le chat
qui pense que les joueurs pourraient
être tentés de tricher
bon là on fait quand même confiance
toute façon les parties sont vérifiés
après je pense qu'on ne peut avoir
moindre doute ni sur un joueur ni sur
l'autre ils ont quand même une
réputation à défendre
il n'y a pas énormément d'argent en jeu
pour leurs standards et et les parties
en elles-mêmes semblent montrer que les
joueurs ne jouent pas avec une
assistance quelconque
après si on voulait encore plus
professionnalisées se se formant
pourrait les faire jouer dans des dans
des théâtres ou dans des salles un peu
comme à la paris games week
mais là pour le moment cette sécurité là
pour les speechs s suffit les joueurs
sont corrects et il n'y a pas de
problème dans les speech est ce que
c'était un championnat du monde avec un
million d'euros à la clé peut-être mais
là j'en étais à 50000 ou soixante mille
dollars de prix les joueurs qui ont
l'habitude de gagner ces sommes-là tout
au long de l'année dans tous les
tournois
donc on leur fait quand même confiance
là c'est vraiment des sommes assez pas
envie dire dérisoire mais c'est pas des
grosses sommes pour ces joueurs là il a
une réputation à défendre
en plus ces partis sont quand même après
à vérifier s'ils jouent tous les coups
de l'ordi ça va se voir donc n'ya pas
y'a pas de problème donc ouest et qu'ils
continuent après ses seins il ya
toujours la plus son pion de plus mais
il a toujours va il peut récupérer le
pion à il peut prendre trois prendre 3
prendre des 4 maxime qui peut pas aller
chercher l'eau tam et peut faire
touriste 6h si c'est tout reprend à 5
ans maxime qui va récupérer le pion et
tour des 5 tours 7
ce qui va tenter roi b6 et c 5 ques les
os qui va la jouer gestionnaire tour 17
donc c'est qui la joue quand même pour
gagner il est un peu mieux il ya le
fiancé qui avancent plus facilement que
le pion à il a raison de l'attenté
wesley s'ils veulent attenter vous faire
ses cinq tours 6 trois des cinq tours h6
c4est sait ce qu'il fait et le joueur
américain qui en blitz et plus et plus
agressif un que lorsqu'il joue en en
partie longue
il tente le bas tout attention à maxime
l'a quand même le pion le pion est parti
à la baisse est qui et qui est dangereux
à quatre très bons coups avec l'idée
suroît prend 1,4 de fer tour c'est ici
c'est maintenant la question c'est est
ce que roy c5 est jouable tout rage
suite il peut peut-être même fait retour
des six pour pour faire un genre de pour
faire un genre de pont lu sénat tension
maximale a quand même ça pourrait ça
pourrait mal se passer
côté français il fait froid ces six avec
la même idée
et surtout rage six tours des six tours
h 8 et peut-être surtout rage 6 même
faire un roi des 5 ou un autre truc
ouais ça semble difficile pour maxim roy
c7 est la tour revient pas du tout en
réalité on n'arrive même pas à sacrifier
contre le pion maxime qui abandonnent et
qui perd une nouvelle partie avec les
blancs c'est vrai que c'est bas c'est le
problème hein on voit on voit le
problème de max qui est souvent souvent
même en tournoi avec les blancs de
vraiment prendre l'aventage contre ses
joueurs du top niveau et l'à une
nouvelle fois on voit on voit un maximum
petites difficultés avec les blancs
ouais c'est assez difficile alors je
suis un peu les tchats 1 pour voir un
peu ce qui se passe rien de rien de
spécial je vous laisse discuter donc on
a de nouveau une une al zor fait sur h3
il n'a pas rejouer cinq maxime pour pas
se reprend les ventes à 4 4 il a changé
et non quoi c'est qui va essayer de
jouer pour l'espace avec les pions qui
bloque pas mal de choses mais bon il
s'est affaibli sur cases noires beaucoup
de pions sur blanc donc forcément les
cases noires sont un petit peu délaissé
alors je n'ai pas non plus une part je
suis pas trop le jeu chalain dragon d'or
pour un genre de ragots dorff donc à 5
tours ces huit dames d2 ces genres de
mike position que maxime joue très bien
ce que j'ai le premier message du chat
non non j'ai pas tout les j'en ai raté
un parce que j'ai regardé assez
intensivement l'aller les parties depuis
le début du coup je profite un peu de
lire le chat là pour pour faire une
petite coupure ce que mine de rien c'est
pas si évident que ça de rester
concentré a commenté pendant quatre
heures d'affilée
j'ai besoin parfois de prendre un peu de
vin peu de recul alors le cavalier c3
qui a attaqué on l'a souvent vous je
suis là soit en plus je suis là sont où
je suis l'arrêt et maxime qui fait dame
c3 et qui s'installe sur cette case c3
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont en train
de bien se passer une nouvelle fois
partie avec les noirs sont maîtrisés
côté côté français
il veut s'en prend à finhan psf pour le
moment où wesley a frappé le premier
mais rien n'est rien n'est fait on voit
des deux va faire tours fc 8 imagine à
tourelle suite attention à kkb d'ici six
ont pu reprendre du cavale et le fou
jaillit sur la diagonale trop bien toi
de et la mac ce qui doit qui doit faire
mal donc faut pas qu'ils se fassent au
pouce et graduellement avec des cavs a
lieu de fous des quatre c4 faut réussir
à maintenir cette pression même à
l'augmenter touquet réfléchit on voit
les deux jours à la caméra qui sont
concentrés et wesley maxime
ce sont des athlètes oui c'est qu'il ya
mon avis a bien bien envie de rajouter
en une victoire en speech s à son
palmarès l'année dernière comme vous
allez dire il avait déjà montré de
grosses qualités et doit bien avoir
envie de cette année de finalement
battre hikaru qui semble un petit peu en
perte de vitesse quand même car où que
ce soit sur internet ans
en partie rapide là le grand duché ce
tour il un peu en fond de classement sur
le général en partie longue il a pas mal
baissé aussi car ou qui semble un peu en
perte de vitesse et est ce que cette
année pourrait encore garder son titre
en speech s
on a là on a le droit de de se poser la
question en tout cas cette année à
l'écart ou stream trop mais en escrime
beaucoup hein c'est vrai que s'expriment
beaucoup là c'est bien joué et et ses
cinq tours c5 pardon parce que si
lecavalier bouge en deux il va voir
cavaler f3 échec intermédiaire roi
bougent et tout reprendre et cinq échecs
et suroît c1 il ya tour prend b3 donc
c'est très bien jouer ce tour c'est 5
est-ce que p4 b4 ça va affaiblir ses
quatre donc ça se fait bon pour max
aussi il reste f4 dans les couloirs
garder est juste un petit cahier 17 de
max confions des 5 va être va être très
fragile elle à la position semblent
bonnes pour maxime
on va voir
on va voir je vois pas comment voix
s'élèvent à pouvoir colmater tous les
trous maxime qui a pas vraiment de
menaces à l'heure actuelle mais il
menace de menaces et sociaux qui domine
mais bon il si maxime gagne cela il ya
un point ça va très vite comme d'un sens
d'un sens que vos relations avec le
cavaliere trois échecs avait peut-être
trois c'est un tour prend b3 j'ai réussi
à [ __ ] en bessin il faut prendre ou
prend pardon j'ai halluciné
j'espère que maxime a pas eu la même à
destination parce que sinon c'est foutu
en fait parce que c'est une
hallucination total en fait ce que les
deux tours sont attaqués
nef s'est tue peu halluciné en fait est
oublié de penser qu'il ya que c'est trop
attaquer mais assez 5 au 6 mai tour
c'est cette repli le problème c'est que
tu fais ça ça à ça il ya l emprise alors
après tu peux encore jouer avec tout
reprend ses droits et tu vas pas
abandonné 1 la torah delà du mal à
sortir et ça va encore mais c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle
oui bon il fait on prend des saints qui
est mieux du coup mais ça devait pas
être
ouais il a dû halluciner exactement
pareil mais c'est tellement facile en
fait cette hallucination
après ça va parce qu'il peut encore
récupérer à 5
il a deux pions pour la qualité il ya
aucun problème
mais après vu le temps qu'il a pris et
qu'il a réfléchi après après ça c'est
qu'il a c'est ce qu'il a il a eu une
hallucination mais bon sa position était
tellement bonne et le coup était pas
forcément mauvais en soi deux pions pour
la qualité c'est à peu près égales c'est
à peu près équilibrés généralement moi
je préfère les deux pions mais ça dépend
vraiment des positions là c'est
peut-être une position où camille a plus
trop de pièces la tour vous fort à mon
avis à peu près à peu près égale ça mon
avis à peu près égales
roy ces deux j'imagine qu'il veut
ramener son roi rapidement maxime qui va
vouloir ramener son roi ici fessé 5 vite
s'ils sont à mon avis beaucoup plus dur
à jouer pour les blancs en blitz parce
que tu peux te faire magouilles et d'un
coup il prend pas pour le moment parce
que s'il prenait la tour rentrer le roi
qui va bien venir en 17
il ramène un peu le cavale il va le
mettre où ce cas valent ce qu'ils valent
maintenant 17 f6 ce qu'ils valent
m'attend c'est 6 avec l'idée est de
jouer b 5 à 5,4 c'est un peu risqué
d'envoyer des pions on va voir on va
essayer qui veut liquider un maximum de
matériel
cette position devrait aller vers la nul
mais on n'est pas à l'abri d'une gaffe
que ce soit d'un côté ou de l'autre
c'est plutôt maxime qui pressent un
salut à raphaël dans le chat nous
demande si sow et mieux je pense que
personne n'est mieux mais cela qui a
bien joué puisque sur wade cet époux c5
il a mis le pion à f/5 il peut faire
jusqu'à 6 max non mais les blancs vont
jamais rentrés nulle part ici même
l'écart et lieusaint qu'un peuvent
traîner pour aller prendre g4
s'accentueront dangereux pour les pour
les blancs ce genre de truc pour moi les
blancs sont pas mieux envie de fo qui la
sauve ou quoi moi ya pas vraiment
davantage blanc ici
qui l'empêchent cavaliers ou 5 max fait
fou aux 5 et ça va faire nul mais
personne n'a la vente à dc a laissé bien
pour maxime
maintenant avec les blancs il va falloir
enfin enfin trouvé quelque chose un
petit peu quelque chose eh ouais c qui
change qui joue une anglaise classique
donc c'est simplement une sicilienne
retourner au final j'ai envie de dire
j'ai envie de dire c'est juste une
sicilienne
avec un temps de plus pour pour les
noirs pour les blancs ça dépend comment
vous dans quel sens vous voyez ça en
tout cas
position qui peut convenir à maxime
s'il réussit à prendre à prendre un
petit avantage
ce serait bien enfin d'avoir un petit
quelque chose avec les blancs est de
réussir à mettre à mettre une vraie
pression sur son adversaire et j'ai
envie de dire au delà d'une répression
faire de la répression sursaut de
répression avantage qui paraît trop
grand ce qu'elle a changé complètement
de répertoire avec les blancs et écoute
je sais pas ça c'est pas mon domaine d
expertise pour conseiller des joueurs
d'un niveau si élevé
il faut soi-même être un joueur de tout
premier plan dont qui à mon avis a que
des personnes ayant au moins fait partie
du top 100 mondial qui peuvent vraiment
aider maxima à construire un répertoire
convenable et je dirais même des anciens
membres du top 50 voire même 30 pour
pouvoir conseiller des joueurs de ce
niveau là en dessous ça me paraît être
des conseils de supporters et des
conseils un peu à côté à côté de la
plaque
après
un répertoire ça peut être aussi un
choix de carrière
est ce que tu veux prendre le risque de
tomber pour monter la deal a été top 20
mondial ouais mais est ce que tu veux
prendre le risque de perdre des parties
de perdre ton et l'eau et de père ton
confort était revenu pour tenter de
progresser en changeant de répertoire où
est ce que tu préfères gérer ta carrière
maxime et qu'un numéro quatre mondial ce
qui est quand même fantastique
est-ce que tu as vraiment envie de
prendre le risque de retomber à la 20e
place 15e 20e place engendre répertoire
alors que tu est assurée en gardant tous
répertoires de rester dans le top 10
voire même top 5 mondial
c'est vraiment une décision difficile à
prendre et c'est j'ai envie de dire des
choix compliqués quoi c'est des gros
risque à prendre
c'est des risques de carrière c'est un
peu comme comme si vous travaillez dans
une dans une bonne société déjà de
prendre le risque de vous mettre à votre
compte pour pour avoir un travail plus
intéressant et éventuellement gagner
plus d'argent mais avec le risque de
tout perdre vous perdre beaucoup
c'est pas c'est pas des choix facile à
faire donc ce qu'elles sont frais dans
les situations dans une situation comme
maxime moi je pense je garderai mon
répertoire enfin je me battrai pas wayne
rooney s'est mis à jouer 4 parce qu'ils
s'ennuient et surtout un maxi 1000 est
jeune et pas si jeune et annecy quand
ils changent le répertoire où il faut un
an et demi deux ans pour retrouver son
son top et qu'il le trouve pas david 32
33 ans 32 33 ans était déjà plus si
jeune peut-être c'est un choix qui
aurait fallu faire plus tôt je sais pas
ou peut-être que le bon choix c'est de
ne pas changer de répertoire c'est
difficile à dire
c'est très difficile à dire et on n'est
pas dans sa tête ait quoi que ce soit et
pendant qu'on parle et ça justement il
ya une nouvelle défaite blanche parce
que les cases blanches autour du roi de
maxime était bien trop faible et on voit
maxime vraiment là-dessus
ce match de speech à ce que je vous
disais un sabot est du speech et ça a
beau être des compétitions un peu
différente
dans tous les cas on retrouve les points
forts et les points faibles de tout un
chacun
donc point faible de maxime le jeu avec
les blancs et le bât blesse avec les
blancs finalement il n'y a pas de pas de
changement par rapport aux compétitions
en partie long qu'on a l'habitude de
voir les points forts et les points
faibles restent pas sûr qu'en tant que
prouve que supporters on a aidé c'est
plus facile hein mais sow est vraiment
vraiment fort et j'ai l'impression
danser dans ces formats que ce soit le
960 le blitz le speech est censé format
un peu plus tranquille je le sens
beaucoup plus fort je le sens plus
détendu plus agressif plus précis il
porte la mention de 960 c'était pas une
question d'internet puisqu'il a gagné
sur l'échiquier en face à west et sont
donc
il manque un peu de un peu d'idées alors
là il a fait un dragon accéléré il a
voulu changer d'ouverture peut-être un
peu je pas si l'anti le temps parce
qu'il avait décidé de ne pas jouer full
full répertoire 1
à la question pour sow c'est ce que tu
rentres dans la finale
ou est-ce que tu gardes les dames
peut-être un coup comme d'un f3
intéressant ici pour wesley qui pourrait
menacer à vii est préparée du
développement fmo f4 n'y aura peut-être
dams et 5 pour max pour tenir le truc
réattaquer regagner un tempo sur le fou
on va voir combien ça c'est comment ça
ça se développe ce dragon accéléré il
reste douze minutes de jeu dans la
cadence normalement encore deux parties
maxime est quand même mené 6-3 donc
l'écart est quand même important en
faveur du joueur américain
on s'attendait peut-être pas un tel
écart si rapidement dans le match maxime
qui fait faut aussi ce probablement fut
f4 intermédiaire ici qui semble
intéressant et maxime un peu un peu dans
le dur malheureusement aller il faut
qu'il s'accroche il faut qu'il
s'accroche
cette fois quatre dames des satires père
un thème pour l'été tour d un encore
pour regagner encore un tempo sur cette
dame
voilà maxime qui est vraiment dans le
dur est peut-être cavaliers p5 aussi
comme candidat qui peut arriver car elle
et b5 ici est marrant à mais a pu
reprendre
ça va et puis on prend fou prend échec
et surtout prend ses quartiers hisser
cette cavale et bessat qui a été joué et
maxime qui a abandonné
et oui oui on pouvait on pouvait rien
faire qui a et b 5 puis on croit il faut
prendre b5 is a matter est fou prend ces
quatre cas et c'est cette on l'avait vu
qu'elle est b57 trois là ça commence à
tourner à la correction nada il faut que
maxime s'accroche à la c
ça commence à être de plus en plus cher
ça commence à faire cher il va falloir
mettre les points parce que c'est pas
wesley qui va qui va ralentir la cadence
on retrouve une de ses positions un peu
symétrique est il un petit le t1 sur la
dernière il a un petit peu tilté allez
il faut faut s'accrocher et rien n'est
perdu dans ce match quatre points c'est
beaucoup et peu à la fois
ce qu'il faut c'est pas sombrer et pas
se retrouver à - 6 - 7 là ce serait
vraiment rédhibitoire maintenant on n'a
plus trop le droit à l'erreur il faut au
moins arriver aux bulles est à - 2 - 3
donc il va falloir il va falloir
recoller au score
allez je vous paie ici ça à troyes le
cavaly qui va repartir vers détroit
cavalli c4 défend le pion sur qui est
français on va faire peut-être apprendre
tout reprend b5 cavalia 5-fu prend b2 et
peut-être cavaliers qui arrive en c6
gagne un tempo sur la dame n'en il part
en 3 et surtout prend b2 qu'est ce qu'il
veut il veut récupérer b5 mais il peut
pas parce qu'il ya x 6 enfilade wallace
et il me semble là que maxime est en
train de en train de tilter tout
bêtement alors là il a peut-être encore
du jeu quand même allez ça va peut-être
on est peut-être un peu un peu inquiet
pour rien dans cette partie mais c'est
vrai que ça fait mal de voir baisser la
enfilé ont filé les points comme des
perles
tu as fait réussi six coups responsable
à les bacs s'il faut il faut recoller
c'est maintenant c'est sur cette partie
qu'il faut vraiment revenir dans le
match
ouais depuis temps à 901 mais ouais
c'est qui est impressionnant c'est
dommage qu'ils réussissent pas à jouer
de cette même manière dans l'est dans
les tournois tout au long de l'année
parce qu'il est vraiment vraiment
vraiment impressionnant c'est ils trient
précis soit + 3 minimum ses sept
victoires sur 7 en speech est wayne on
en a trois à plus 3 ouest gso c'est sûr
que normalement il n'est ce pas il
laisse pas sa proie ce s'en sortir mais
bon
maxime c'est quand même un joueur
exceptionnel
donc j'y crois encore 1,6 réussi déjà à
gagner là il ya bien plus trois en il va
prendre la pause les dix minutes cinq
minutes de pause à il va pouvoir pouvoir
ce pouvoir réfléchir tranquillement et
peut-être a décidé la voilà ce qui finit
par faire une gaffe fils le pion v5
mains d'un prêt pions prend b5 tour
prend des 5
il y aura plus x 6 grâce à tour prend b
8 qui retouchera la dame est sûre fou et
catherine vous prenez trois tours prend
des huit doigts mais il ya un cahier
prend 1,5 à la fin la mince j'ai cru à
une gaffe mais le problème c'est que
c'est maxime qui a gaffé en réalité et
qui a filé les deux pions 103 ou wesley
a non à tout tout va pour le mieux du
monde pour pour le joueur américain et
maxime un camp sous comme souvent quand
il déjoue un peu qu'ils commencent à
jouer très vite ils jouent tous tempo il
joue à toute blinde et sens là on l'a vu
dans les matches à plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises on a vu un maxime comme ça on
dit détente jouer à toute blinde tout
tempo alors évidemment il est même en
jouant comme ça il encore mille fois
plus fort que le commun des mortels mais
là il joue pas contre le commun des
mortels justement ils jouent contre 1
contre un joueur du top niveau et j'ai
peur qu'on soit en train de le voir
encore un petit peu déjoué aller maxime
il faut s'accrocher
il faut mettre les point là le fou qui
arrive en d4 c'est très bien joué de la
part de wesley le fou qui va taper f de
maxime qui peut pas taper f7 et wesley
qui va pouvoir construire sa partie avec
ses deux pions plus cette partie là
semble dur maxime propose des changes
des dames et il va essayer de tenir la
finale mais là on joue on joue pour
éviter - 5 5 points d'écart ça serait
vraiment vraiment dur alors est-ce qu'il
va échanger ou essai par tour ces trois
là il peut y avoir des fous de couleurs
opposées
ça peut encore ça peut encore se sauver
pour le français et là c'est vraiment
primordial de de prendre un demi point
dans cette partie 5la on va comme je lui
dis à - 6 - 7 on rentre vraiment dans la
zone où à mon avis la plus plus grand
chose à faire - 5 on serait à une
défaite de de la cata on serait bien
quand même de rester à moins 4 ans dans
la foule couleurs opposées
est ce qu'elle est gagnant de celles là
bonne question il a un pion pas cessé il
a un pion de plus de l'autre côté le
pion à ce n'est pas forcément sur la
bonne couleur
il faut ici c'est bien joué il provoque
g5 il veut fou aux cinq maintenant le
roi par ici pour défendre les pions et
droit passe de l'autre côté c'est gagné
pour pour wesley puisqu'il aurait pu
faire jouer le fou contre le roi et le
roi contre le fou on sait qu'en foot
couleur opposée c'est ce qu'il faut
faire et ça fait plus 5
il passe à la france est dans la maxime
qui a la tête sous l'eau c'est c'est
difficile de voir maxime comme ça c'est
difficile on le voit on le voit sombre
et sow qui jouent mieux alors après
maxime peut être aussi un peu un peu la
tête ailleurs après sa désillusion
contre gries tchouk et avec la grosse
échéance de jérusalem qui arrive mais ça
aurait été bon pour le moral quand même
de faire un bon match
il faut vraiment que maxime trouve la
force de femmes là pour gagner dans une
française et revenir au score alors non
il balance pas le match du train il
n'est pas venu avec l'intention de
perdre le match avant un maxime je vous
rassure c'est juste que ils jouent ils
jouent contre quelqu'un qui est très
fort très précis qui fait peu d'erreurs
et et c'est difficile le match se passe
mal et maxime qui réussit pas qui
réussit pas à revenir dedans et on sait
quest et son point fort c'est pas perdre
est ce qu'il ya un des quatre qui
marchaient à un moment donné on s'est
fait des cats et qui prend des 4 ou pas
et loire voyez qu'il prend des quartiers
prend des quatre mois y avait des ventes
sur l'ordi donne des trucs un peu
compliqué bon ça devait être théorique
j'imagine c'est pas énorme que je joue
donc je connais pas mais les deux
joueurs ont joué à toute blinde
alors il fait le fou prend h7 wesley ce
qui est vraiment une attaque de maths
ici il est quand même incroyable se voit
et c'est ce soir damages cette 3ème
fuite a du coup j'ai laissé leur dis
donc il dit à mach 5 avantage décisif le
pion à vii sera plus défendable
d'habitude je ne mets pas la turbine
mais a comme je l'aï dit à ma tête ça
aide à mach 5 et tu peux rien faire pour
éviter dame prend f7 g6 d'un match 7 et
tu arrives cette tombe si vous êtes les
trouve ça ça va faire plus 6 voilà ça va
ça va faire cher au sein et puis si ça à
faire chez roth
on va voir mais il est juste
impressionnant reste les 1,6 à six trous
voit ça à faire saut ouais c'est ça va
faire cher
ça va être chaud voilà wesley so qui est
chirurgical abandon de maxime encore une
partie en 5 + 1 il ya déjà 9 3
ouais c'est une démonstration d'oiselets
qui écrase le joueur français vraiment
est maximale à kiev 4 et l'on peut plus
là il est il est ko debout maxime il est
ko maxime place et aurait il tente y
tente tente labeur mais il y est plus
voilà il a plu à tête à sa maxime c'est
terrible c'est terrible incroyable ce
qui est en train d'arriver
j'avais vraiment pas peuvent prévu ce
genre de scénario la la ça flanche
complètement
c'est pour ça y est je vous disais qu'il
fallait vraiment souligner la
performance quand même de deux dingli
rennes qui avait été solide dans la tête
pour pour rester dans le match contre
eux n'est pas même s'il était très
dominés
là il a du mal il a du mal maxima rester
à rester dans le match aller est basse
et cela sur des blancs balla ouais
j'aime bien moi mais je pense qu'il va
la gagner maxell citrouille que oui j ai
4 non là ça va aller la maxime qui va
peut être collée à cinq points je suis
toujours je suis confiant en compte le
come back est possible parce qu'il ya
sept points d'écart mais six points
d'écart mais il reste encore 2 cadence
s'il réussit à gagner salaire revient à
cinq points c'est faisable la sueur
petit rock il y avait qu à vannes et des
cinq pour jouer les clous âge
sa position est quand même assez assez
intéressante il a beaucoup de jeu au
centre ce que l'apôtre istres est le
symptôme qu'il travaille beaucoup pour
les parties longues et qui n'est pas
dans le monde des blitz ouais c'est
possible aussi
après même cédé match avec un enjeu plus
faibles t'as jamais envie de perdre un
match de cette manière là pour la
confiance c'est pas très bon après
maxime c'est quelqu'un qui réussit à
bien tourner la page de ces défaites et
qui réussit à bien repartir et à rester
positif
il est sûr de son niveau donc ça lui
fera moins mal qu'à quelqu'un d'autre
mais tu vois la même même pour la suite
on préférait face et mieux s'y perd pas
le match avec tous treize points d'écart
parce que c'est par moment donné en fait
ça fait quand même n'était fait lourder
même c'est notre cadence même si c'est
autre chose ça te met pas en confiance
et c'est qui rend un des deux pions de
plus allez maxime
vu comment est en train et maxime qui a
la tête dans le seau exactement vous
précis c'est intéressant l'idée c'est
que sur foot prend ici si on veut
probablement un damage cinq échecs du
coup sûr d'un rêve cette sueur et dames
prévu 7 3 points f7 et tour f1 pour
jouer sur le clouage maxima kia qui a
bien joué là je pense va t'en
difficultés sony prend f5 prise g8 prix
g7 ou g8
il ya du tour eiffe un intermédiaire
peut-être mesdames g6 pénible après il
peut jouer sur fois-ci s'il veut faire
d'alger 6
ouais mais bon après on recule le fou
bon allez ça là ça se passe bien faut
vraiment qu'il a conclu maxime et qui
prennent le point il fait dame c4 a été
encore plus fort bien joué
l'idée c'est que sur tours g7 il fait
dame ces six dames à 8 et en plus si
court g2 donc ques les qui va faire
froid 17 ça semble être le coup pour
protéger ici et maintenir la menace la
moitié autre chose il fait grand qu il
décide que le roi est plus en sécurité
là-bas c'est peut-être pas faux c'est
vrai que l' avantage c'est qu'il y aura
pas quand il fait d'armes français deux
genres fois schiste dame français deux
silhouettes en dix-sept j'avais damev
cet échec est là sur damas is here
partie en 17 arrêts c'est bien jouer
grand roque à il est bon sur un qui est
vraiment bon
bon mais peut-être me faire foirer fils
et sur dame ces deux tours 2 on attaque
et il n'y a pas d'échec
et quand la dame repart ont poussé 6
mais peut-être un autre coup sûr fois je
sais ce qui m'échappe 1 à foisches issia
peut-être d'alger 6 du coût menace le
fouet manager 2 et il n'y a pas d'échec
paisible et voir ce que dit le redis ice
avantage ici pour les noirs maintenant
fallait trouver fois ci c'est sûr dame
j'ai six dames france et 6 quand même et
laissé en haïti c'est caraïbes et 5 très
logique aussi si on le voit mais max qui
a fait tour f1 voilà d'où j'ai rallumé
l'ordi pour voir et maintenant d'amener
les six bons maxime qui va pm prendre si
si c'est ça va être chaud mois les max
faut se battre
rien n'est fait
wen en sotchi et qui a ses chirurgies
carrément match-là pour le moment il est
très impressionnant vraiment non lé
salah il faut que maxime fasse un peu un
tour de magie il est très bon dans ses
positions
sophie est hyper concentré on le voit la
caméra il a les mains il a la tête dans
les mains il est concentré à 200% il
sait que maxime est très dangereux il
veut pas laisser un millimètre à maxime
il sait que si maxime se met en route
qu'il en gagne 2,3 après notre max il
peut il peut devenir imprenable donc il
veut vraiment interdire empêcher tout
retour du numéro un français est lui
garder la tête sous l'eau c'est vraiment
vraiment sa stratégie d'empêcher que
maxime ne reviennent et ne se chauffe
pour revenir dans le match donc là c'est
la dernière partie de la cadence et
celles qui veulent même pas il peut
faire froid ces 8es prendre la nulle
improbablement croit ces huit dames
assiste que suroît ossature accueille
des cinq pour max donc ça va sûrement se
solder par une nulle mais même là un
saut qui qui veut tenter
il fait froid aussi ça et me maintient
la pression dame c4 et peut-être il va
faire des 5 et peut-être qu'il va faire
des cinq ici 3,17 il est sage
il va pas faire des 5
il va prendre là nul il maintient son
plus si c'est comme ça il s'assure que
maxime passe une mauvaise pause sans
avoir réussi à marquer deux points d un
qui était jouable même et wesley qui way
qui jouent vraiment bien humaine y mène
9-3 c1 c'est un scénario qu'on n'avait
pas imaginé ça qu'il y avait il y avait
quoi il y avait 2,2 et tout d'un coup il
ya eu 3 2 il ya eu 4 3 et puis et puis
sow s'est envolé sceaux s'est envolé et
il a enchaîné les points maxime qui a
enchaîné les mauvaises parties avec les
noirs il a quitté la nage dorff et il a
été un peu en tilt ce qui va se passer
maintenant c'est qu'on va faire
une pause il va y avoir six minutes de
pub les mecs c'est en soutien à la
chaîne atx eskom et à la compétition
l'équipe pour la peine est organisé par
13 points comme donc on va se mettre la
petite pub qui fait plaise on va se
retrouver dans six minutes de ça pour
espérer une remonte à la rien n'est rien
est impossible encore il reste du temps
si maxime recolle un peu qui peut gagner
+ 3 le 3 plus sain et plus 3 2 1 + 1 il
est quand même bon ambühl est donc on va
on va rester on va espérer qu'ils se
reprennent espérer que sauveur il ya un
coup de mou un moment donné qui donne un
une deux trois parties avec maxime sur m
on se rappelle qu'il a été bien remonté
contre eux wailly donc rien n'est perdu
on se retrouve après la pause à tout de
suite les mecs
alors les mecs
je vais arrêter rêviez qu'on va rester
sur ces images que je sais qu'ils refont
des transitions on va rester sur robert
s et un orange qui sont en train de
discuter et dany qui doit dire c'est la
m
robert pour maxime c'est là c'est là
c'est l'art scrs
ils vont refaire une transition voilà
avec le score logique en cinq points
c'est quand même une victoire de sony
victoire de 5-3 puis ça et maxime qui
devait un peu revenir en 1 + 1 d'après
l'algo donc bon mais il devait perdre à
moins de hyper à moins 6 c'est pas
forcément terminée terminée allez on va
y croire on s'accroche à ce qu on peut
hein on s'accroche aux branches là on
s'accroche aux branches
parce qu'il ya pas grand chose d'autre à
quoi à quoi s'accrocher
max qui est dans le dans le dur dans le
très dur dans le piquant il va falloir
se réveiller et frappés en fin d'année
qui sut il est issu et nous on va
repartir sur notre came fond vert
échiquier verts on est on est on est on
est on est vers en des ovaires on est au
vert à les maxima il va falloir se
sortir tu sais quoi de tu sais où j'ai
envie de dire ouais c'est de la poésie
c'est du cdu commentaires poétiques mais
c'est un peu c'est un peu la seule
chance un de de réussir à way au moins
au moins à se remettre un petit peu
quand même un petit peu et se relancer
dans le match quoi c'est sa faux faux
faux ouais faut revenir à mentalement
dans ce match moi ça c'est important
c'est vraiment la première chose à faire
c'est remettre mentalement dans le match
je recommence à prendre des points et
après on
ah non les parties semblent pas avoir
forcément repris jeu quand même vérifier
ça pas encore repris et la demi-finale
sera intérêt certain dans tous les cas
on verra ce que ça donne avec artemiev
il te parle de la femme battle afc
l'événement qui font juste après moi j'y
crois parce que là on verra si c'est
marrant mais j'ai pas le fameux battle
bon je suis pas fan battle en duo ça
sympa ça m'a pas ça pas impressionné
c'est quoi ce concept c'est du cdh
humains cerveau avec avec les médias
nova et rudolf d'un côté et beauté et sa
soeur peut-être de l'autre ou jennifer
chat déchets pas mais c'est un concept
qui me qui m'impressionne pas les îles
une vente classique de la sicilienne la
camorra fils qui sait si ça fait une
richter a aux heures c'est texte qui
anime le fam bat sun nah et j'aime pas
trop ces trucs de prendre des filles
pour prendre des filles mais ouais c'est
pas tu sais que ça marche après un ski
tricolore c'est de faire un mix une
femme fait la main et un homme fait du
cerveau et tension du duo tu a glissé là
tu fais que c'est bigard de l'autre
équipe
ouais non c'est cool de prendre des
filles mais après bon sont prises aux
cinq prises cinq quoi c'est qui va en
faire la fia reste moi avoir un jeu de
l'oie ses gestionnaires qui prend des
vite maxime qui va reprendre du fou ou
de la dame une tour qui va revenir en d1
donc là en réalité il ya un roc opposé
mais les joueurs qui vont pas vraiment
attaqué le roi adverse
messieurs à l'issue là en tout cas pour
le moment mais qui vont plutôt joué pour
le contrôle du centre pour le moment et
maxime car en réalité une position
solide il veut faire tour c'est 8
il n'ya pas fou prend 1,6 pour prendre
17 parce que surtout price ici à four
prend à m6 donc il n'ya pas de n'y a pas
de souci là-dessus et max qui veut juste
faire tour ces 8es contre attaque et
peut-être un jour damev 2 pouces et 7 et
les pièces blanches qui vont se faire
chasser pour le moment c'est une partie
qui commence plutôt bien et merci à eux
outre 21 keith abonnés kouichi prime
merci tonton donc f5 joué par soi et ce
n'est donc il veut pas laisser le temps
aux pièces du joueur français de
s'organiser sur tours c8 du coup il veut
juste prendre réussissent probablement
et venir mettre une pression de dingue
donc sur cavaliers g4 il va faire dame
f4 et protégera le fou donc ya pas de
problème là-dessus va pas de problème
c'est jouable mais je n'y a pas de il
n'y a pas de gain et f5 qui semble
semble être un coup intéressant du coup
pour pour wesley qui laisse pas un tour
ses huit tours ces cinq courses et 8
pouces et 7 en tout cas l état mme la
dame s'infiltre en f2 non kg 4 jouer
quand même d'un mec 4 maxime on sait
qu'ils aiment bien jouer les variantes
un peu forcé iapteff sabira pas vraiment
f5 emprise ya 17 ans prise à la fin donc
le carlit d'en revenir en effet 6 alors
maintenant
ou essayer qui peut toujours rien faire
avance devant le roi de maxime donc ça
semble à aller way la position semble
correct pour les pour les deux joueurs
pour les blancs comme les noirs ça peut
très bien liquidant aussi stupide et de
partout c'est d'ailleurs ce que les
joueurs sont en train de faire maxime
qui reprend 2 f bon espion russie ce qui
est un peu faiblard mais d'un autre côté
truc c'est que le roi dans le grand
roque est souvent moins moins bien
protégée dans ce genre de situation et
ouais c'est qui va directement pour les
changes des dames y perd pas de temps
l'américain il veut échanger échangés
aient changé il veut échanger les dames
mais le rend bien il a bien raison
maxime qui peut pas vraiment de gratter
h2 parce qu'il y avait sept en l'air
maintenant il ya eu six en l'air et il
envoie g4 c'est bien joué j'ai quatre à
la part de joueurs américains pour
mettre le pion angers 5 mai la cavalier
des singles être jouable pour maxime
puisque la dame protège la tour en tout
cas il semble que ça soit maintenant
possible ça va quand même échangé d'un
f3 est donc il va jouer le pion isolé
des cinq salariés isolés passé et il va
peut-être jouer le roi du coup en fait
c'est le roi des des noirs qui a un poil
plus faibles et peut-être se prendre une
tour en d4 un de ces quatre noms il fait
h4 à maxime qui encaisse le pion
comprend des cinq îles rhume et la toux
rang et fuite ça va ya pas de souci ça
va échangeurs quel roi est le plus en
sécurité c'est quand même le roi blanc
parce qu'il n'ya pas de marc étions
devant lui et le roi noir peut être un
peu notre sauce mousse j'ai envie de
dire mais bon est-ce que il va y avoir
mieux que des perpète je pense pas sûr
h5 ya déjà d'un machin d'un match 5
bon là ça va finir en perpète nom d'un
machin d'un match 4 et dames
quoique il va prendre et ce qui peut
aller prendre bessette
on va voir
on va voir d'amd ati siens tout maxime
sait qui de toute façon je pense pas
qu'un joueur puisse vraiment après le
roi blanc il a plus propension à se
balader à pouvoir essayer d'aller
chercher un peu d des noises en allant
se mettront à 7 en cherchant des dames
p8 dame prend bessette
c'est tout de même plus à maxime de
faire gaffe à mon avis mais bon ça va
tout à fait quand même droit à 3 oui si
maxime prend ici va faire échec échec
peut-être y reviendra protège ouais
c'est ça qui veut faire en fait ça et
j'ai compris j'ai mis le temps mais en
fait il veut gagner ce pion la revenir
protéger suis là et avoir lui passait
alors que maxime mora papillon passé et
donc maintenant il va monter avec le roi
ça j'ai bien j'ai bien compris son plan
haïti afin faire gaffe à des dames des
cinq échecs mais les gagnantes pour
maxime celle là elle est gagnante pour
maxime
il va ramener le roi des sissi l'avions
pas s'éloigner à wesley qui a oublié b6
aller sa part de la maxe ça part de là
je pense qu'avec elle doit gagner on va
mettre laurent des 6 et on va essayer
d'envoyer des 5 à 5 à 4,3 des trois à
temps la difficulté c'est que sur bessin
qui la p4 est sûre à saint qui veut
faire roi c'est qu'à 3 des 6 3 b 5 nom
ne dit me dites pas que c'est pas vrai
il peut pas la gagner peut pas la gagner
parce que parce que sur b5 bkt sur à 5 y
emmèneront en bessin croit il a lieu il
a eu de la chance la wesley il est une
la chance il eu beaucoup de chance ou
est ce l'état aurait pu faire plus
simple un bien joué bien vu maxime qui a
bien résisté et qui a finalement réussi
à mettre en difficulté son adversaire
donc de nouveau maxi avec les blancs qui
tente une attaque est indienne une
nouvelle fois on n'obtient pas grand
chose pour changer
donc faut 6 ouais mais de nouveau c'est
les noirs qui prennent l'espace c'est
les noirs qui ont je sais pas s'ils sont
mieux mais mais ils sont pas moins bien
en fait ça le problème
c'est ça qui est pénible 7b 4 kgs c5 et
c4 pourquoi pas ouais le dernier ce
pitch assez mal mal débuté au 6 mai mais
c'était contre eux oui cette c3 g5 allez
ça va jouer à l'est le roi côté côté
saut et allèles dame côté maxime comme
une indienne
allez il faut se battre à fond des
quatre têtes envoyé baies 5 pouces et 5
le taf et retour des 8es il va falloir
il va falloir mettre la pression sur la
dame de ce soir je sais pas ce que faire
sur tour des huit que rio défendre le
pion tu as juste fois f1 peut-être p5
intermédiaire fouet fin est fou mais
quatre qui vont arriver
voyez un peu de vaisselle qui a cassé et
j'ai entendu ça à 6 quai c'est ça ça me
paraît bien là pour pour maxime
ça me paraît bien pour maxime
c'est là reste à la casse et donc est ce
que fait refouler 6 v6 ou bessette et
trois des huit on va voir vous fait
marrer dans le tchat
alors oui je viens de sortir la réunion
parents-profs pas forcément content et
l'ajout à maxime en train de perdre ça
fait chier van eeckhout c'est pas le
match le plus important
non il y en a treize eric passe
aspirateurs et malgré la porte et tout
ça ça s'entend même d'ici et malgré que
le micro 60 cepal prend pas le prendre
mais qui équipent arranger 6
alors est-ce qu'un truc comme cavalier
prend un truc intéressant c'est qu'il
prend fou prend ses cinq échecs semblait
marcher mais adam 6 pour maxime qui fait
des 4 4 des 5
il pousse au centre à l'est c'est le
bordel surprise en f3 il ya un problème
en 8c parti qui conviennent mieux à
maxime ça allez va falloir en profiter
car il ya eu 5 alors qu'est prend 1,5 et
des quatre mais vrai bien joué et bien
joué et maxime qui vise la case de 6 et
l'a peut-être on va voir un sacrifice de
qualité de la part des os les ou pas
d'ailleurs
est-ce qui va s'en prendre à eux 6 il a
quand même
f5 qui en l'air aussi il fait damer
fuite avait peut-être sur ton prend
aussi ce qui est pris avec 5 quand même
aller il faut il est dans les cordes la
wesley il faut il faut le finir la halle
et maxime a sur cette île encore d'ahmed
7,6 vous à tous il va mettre la tour en
b vite peut-être est-ce là il s'éloigne
il s'en nourrit sans l'aide de cette
diagonale qui était dangereuse
maxime qui va mettre la dame en a deux
j'imagine qu'il va rester assez dominant
sur la diagonale tout de même où il va
faire de cet échec intermédiaire parce
que surtout reprend b3 ya pions et
fuites sur échec et qui l'on prend b3
qui arrive
mais ce que c'est un intérêt de faire
recette damev cette dame preuve c'est
trois points f7 et cavaliers f5
peut-être un ace à l'air sympa à sa
recette
à moins que je rate quelque chose mais
ça a l'air très sympa et 7
je vérifie avec l'ordinaire 7 me sens
très bien
cette variante numéro un mais l'ordi
donne que égal à la fin je sais pas
pourquoi mais au 5e set et le meilleur
coup d'après lord issa d'ailleurs joué
par maxime damev cette prise prise à et
sur cavaliers f5 le problème c'est qu'il
y avait un clouage parce qu'il a pris de
cavaillon f cette maxime qui met la tour
en d1 fou prend des quatre prises des 4
il va faire pour prendre le set
notre ami wesley et il va obtenir en
avantages matériels d'un pion c'est
clair et net cavaliers peu 5 il va y
avoir foule prendre 5 45 ça ça va aller
tout re d un et là il peut y avoir une
tour qui va se balader en b3 c'est ces
jouets et les cavaliers qui tiennent
toutes les cases d'entrée c'est une
horreur
le cavalier qui va venir en d3 le temps
qui est meilleur pour wesley le fou qui
est menacée s'il faut bouger à tour
prend 1 à 3 et là il ya peut-être même
jusqu'à et puis on prend un f3 ou trois
arrêts c'est la cata f4 qui va tout
enfermé allée ouest et qui n'a pas
acquis a pas fait avec 4 qu'il est
peut-être une petite chance à maxime
allez allez max il faut il faut réussir
à prendre les points
mais là pour le moment c'est la cata
mais il peut l'y peu il peut sauver un
demi point ici en jouant vite et bien
parce que les pions de wesley on était
un peu bloquée il s'est créé son propre
contre eux je aller c'est bien c'est
bien ce que fait maxime là pour pour se
sauver ou ac qui a raté f4 à mon avis il
aurait enfermé maxime ça aurait été dur
il n'y a pas tous heureusement là ce qui
menaçait fin dame
aïe aïe aïe et sur ces sept tf1 dame
échec direct à ça fait plus cette salle
elle fait mal ça là il fait très très
mal il y en a eu d'autres qui ont fait
mal mais ça là elle fait mal ça là elle
fait très très mal parce que c'est une
partie qui semblait convenir à maxime
avec les blancs il avait il avait joué à
une position tactique qui pouvaient
qu'ils pouvaient jouer en sa faveur mais
wesley indéboulonnable précis tactique
et une nouvelle fois il réussit à
s'imposer et à et alourdir le score il
veut plus jouer avec vous au f5 maxime
avant une position très correct il doit
connaître
voilà il le joue d'ailleurs et ouais
c'est qu'il va pas prendre mille fois eu
de donc maxime qui a une position très
saine un cavalier des six salles et là
ça se passe bien une nouvelle fois avec
les noirs mais maxime qui fait la gueule
l'om est plus est ça fait mal hein je
vous dise amical mais bon quand même
saleh elle dit que trois puces 1 et même
avec la tactique sont ils gagneraient
c'est inquiétant c'est inquiétant est
enfin là c'est plus qu'inquiétant non il
n'a pas le droit d'abandonner le match
évidemment mais mais là ça devient
difficile hein ça devient très difficile
bon là on est rupture de type carlsbad
maxime qui va pouvoir poser son jeu
voici et qui rend gestion après on
espère on espère toujours à l'idée
d'aider noir basiquement sait tous et b5
bekkat affaiblir le pion c3 d'aller
mettre peut-être quelque chose par la
suite en c4 un cavalier notamment voit
ses qui va essayer d un peu jouer sur la
case e 5
j'ai envie de dire maxime qui se fait
pédagogie fier un parent par le joueur
américain et on voit pas pour le moment
comment il peut revenir
or voici qu'il allait prendre le pion
dessins qu'il a peur de rien et maxime
qui a peut-être encore comme une faute
de calcul ou pas parce que là la dame
semble quand même un sacré danger
attendait a pas du hcc 5 la la dame elle
me semble elle me semble vivre les
heures des heures assez sombre là ce
qu'on veut faire c'est sûr h6 il veut
faire damas fkt sur gt5 je pense il veut
claquer la pièce est jouée cette
position et remettre le fou en d3 et
jouer pour fou et cinq cavaliers à 5 qui
est un peu loin du jeu à mon avis c'est
l'idée de de wesley et si tu fais pas ça
je ne vais même vérifié se passer quoi
sur un fils et j'ai peut-être un peu
revenir en vue quatre équipes rangées 5t
jouable aussi à donner un avantage blanc
et dames eux quatre les deux jeux
vérifier alors dit les deux allées pour
wesley il a fait d'amener 6b quatre
essais 4 francs ses caprices et 4 bon
c'est pas complètement perdu mais c'est
un plomb - et c'est de nouveau dur c'est
de nouveau difficiles on voit ce qu'est
qui vraiment impressionnant saddam qui
revient en d2 c'était logique il va il
va faire j'ai quatre il va chasser le
cavalier et il va aller taper une
chaussette à maxime qui trouve un
intermédiaire sympa en attaquant deux
cavaliers à tour c'est aussi sympa de la
part de wesley intermédiaire contre
intermédiaires et maintenant il peut
prendre prendre prendre et bouger le
cavalier en pays basque y aura plus de 7
en l'air allez maxime lakiha à café qui
a peut-être fait plusieurs dans cette
partie il doit réfléchir à qui prend des
quatre avec l'idée que surtout reprend
ses trois tours prend ces trois dames
français 3 d'avoir cavalier e 2
cheikh france et trois à la fin et
j'imagine que c'est ce qu'il est en
train de calculer si ça marche ça fait
mal allez on peut remonter là et qui
prend des quatre fous prend des quatre
évidemment ou même dame prend mais
plutôt vous prend et on vient martyrisé
le pion le pion et veut aller max là il
peut il peut marquer mais je pense que
je dois faire tout reprendre 7 avec
l'idée surtout rêve 3faire tour 8 3
bougez dame prend des quatre dames prend
est fou et 5 peut-être une finale tu na
ble mais je vois pas pas mieux pour le
joueur américain
allez y est parti là dedans d'ailleurs
très froid tour 8 apprend des quatre il
a vu la vitesse de l'éclair
on va voir ce qu'il réussit à faire
allez allez maxime c'est la folle a
gagné tu arraches 3 enfin deux variantes
il y aura le pion à je crois enfin deux
variantes
ouais mais je veux voir ce que dit leur
dis vous prend avec de très bien jouer
d'après leurs ordis sur dame prend f2i à
tour c'est un roi g2 et je vois pas ce
qu'il ya après manger leur dis donc ça
va aller dams et 6,3 g iii est d'amener
si ça il va toucher la tour d'accord
bien joué pour un f2 très bien joué de
la part de maxime allais la sarre à
gagner il va revenir à six points on va
reprendre espoir
la tour c 2 et d'amd 6
il encaisse la tour et gagne la partie a
laissé bien aller sa part de la maxime
six points d'écart on est revenu à l'est
les amis aller les amis 6 points à
l'élan gagne encore 2 3 et on est là
l'art montana est parti ça faisait
longtemps qu'on attendait cette victoire
et c'est parti j'aimerais faire un petit
point sur le temps il reste 39 minutes
ouais il reste encore il reste encore
cinq six parties dans la cadence si
partie peut-être même encore allez y peu
il peut le faire aller maxime tu peux le
faire on est retourné dans ce plan isolé
il veut il veut il veut faire vendre des
séries didot avec la ddt
c'est bien marketing bravo max allez il
faut il faut y aller mais car il y en a
eu cinq points c'est là qu'ils y y qui
fait un petit un petit mouvement de tête
allait il est dans le dur la west a
laissé le moment de ces le moment
l'enfant de lui mettre la tête dans le
seau justement change de structure
ouais maxime qui et qui fait du
placement de produit je suis quasiment
vide dû écrire en direct la nuit hier
merci max pour ce magnifique placement
de produit tu fait plaise aléas les
pions pendant il va peut-être avoir le
temps de claquer un des cinq bien placé
avec le fou qui va s'ouvrir
le match est en train de tourner les
amis le match est en train de tourner en
notre faveur c'est évident là là on l'a
on commença on commence à rêver à
reprendre espoir maxime qui va qui m'a
envoyé du dessin qui va jouer sur cette
grande diagonale et qui va faire mal à
djems wesley so à l'éval eux il va le
faire vaciller à l'eso qui va vaciller
allez on va envoyer des cinq tôt ou tard
peut-être pas maintenant mais ça va
partir et ça va faire mal
il va le sentir passer à l'est des
singles boom ces partis puis on prend
des cinq tours prend 1,8 ont deux dvi et
on te reprends aller maxime on y va
aller les amis allaient gérard à l'ailé
gérard depardieu dans le tchat
je veux une pluie de gérard dans le
chatt e5 est allé on amène le foin à
trois cavaliers bessin à calais on lui
rentrer dedans on va le faire plier
allez il a repris du poil de la grette
hilare il a tout repris la maxime
c'est un joueur de ré
s'il enchaîne une deux trois quatre
wesley va plus voir le jour wesley en
sueur face au français qui va repartir
en c6 il a plu en cours pour lui et
wesley
ouais c'est en train de en train de
subir wesley en train de subir
allez là il faut faut continuer à faire
mal on sait pas trop comment mais
peut-être un petit coup juger trois fous
j'ai deux on met le fou on protège le
pion tranquillement à défaut s'il faut
il faut un post révolte et là il faut un
sursaut d'orgueil on peut pas se laisser
mourir comme ça il faut aller faut aller
chercher wesley allez on va le chercher
allez maxime allais petit aller l'on
voit ces cinq j'aime bien ça c'est le
beau jeu b c'est fou ces quatre on va
pas le laisser vivre
on va aller on va les chercher on va
aller lui faire mal partout on ne va pas
lui laisser un centimètre de territoire
aux joueurs d'origine philippine a les
dames bessette on joue la finale aller
les gérards on est partout
allez allez les amis ils envoient et
tour à 7 un os qu'on n'a pas laissé
passer notre chance est ce que on n'a
pas laissé passer notre chance parce que
aller loin ont pas mal liquide et il va
peut-être réussir à il va peut-être
réussir à la tenir ça n'a quand même le
pion pas s'éloigner
maintenant quand même il ya un pion
passé à le pion c'est qu'ils aient
bloqué le cavalier qui va qui va mal
joué et merci à pattes maxime pour les
petits petits bis et ça envoie de
partout des émeutes
allez on échange et on fait jouer le
pion à aller on fait par l'espion à les
amis le pion à le pion à aller le pion à
qui va partir à l'est a4 c'est bon allez
il y est allé le pion à comme comme le
pion à gries tchouk il faut l'envoyer il
faut passer les lignes ennemies il faut
revenir à cinq points les amis aller à
cinq points quatre points trois points
on recolle à 3 points j'y crois de
nouveau aller
qui est ici c'est peut-être bien jouer
où il veut c'est très bien défendu c'est
très bien défendu surtout reprend ses
cinq cavaliers prend sur fion prend il
veut faire rater six tours f tour g5 et
f6 il récupère et surtout reprend il va
prendre il va aller choper le truc roman
perd plus mon père plus déjà il va
prendre wade 6 et laurent va venir en b5
et ça va aller mais on n'a pas le temps
tu fais fca 3b 5
bref de roi ici et le roi va avoir le
temps de revenir il pourra faire un
petit m6 m6 ou un petit avis il va
revenir avec le roi et ça va aller
bon bien peut-être encore un petit
pression quand même
eyquem des cas de figure où tu réussi à
rentrer en poussant les pions aller faut
y croire
c'est peut-être pas si clair clair
encore à ces cinq points f4f 6 g5l st
croix au 5 allée maxime mayroy des six
très bien joué puis on prend h 6 or il
est fort à il est fort il est très fort
parce qu'elle était dur à défendre celle
là à trouver roanne et 6h si c'était
beau
impressionnant au fc sion en défense la
impressionnant
allez c'est bien c'est bien il a quand
même forcé ou est ce les a trouvés de la
grosse défense il faut y aller il faut
continuer il va peut-être finir par
craquer maxime qui est en train de
reprendre de reprendre le dessus là je
sens je sens un maxime plus
entreprenants et je le sens reprend le
dessus sur son adversaire et a repris le
dessus sur nate sur son adversaire en
tout cas dans le milieu de jeu il faut
qu'ils réussissent à a continué
peut-être un moment donné de son côté
aussi wesley peut commencer à craquer et
maxime qui pourra en mettre une deux
trois quatre d'affilée et revenir au
score il a que à six points
il ya quand même encore le 1 + 1
derrière aller voir l'objectif de
revenir à plus 4 avant le bullet il
reste trente et une minutes c'est plus
que faisable
ça part de là avec les noirs il a des
bonnes positions avec les blancs là il a
eu une bonne position encore allez on y
croit
allez la maxime c'est bien ça lui
convient tout ça allez on continue on
lui tape dessus l on tape sur la gueule
de sault ya plus que ça à faire aller
chaque coup ça doit être un avec chaque
wii doit lui faire mal allez on fait mal
on fait mal on fait mal on fait mal un
coup une menace un coup une menace allez
lui attaque le feu deux on y reste allez
papa de coûts vite que des coups pour
lui faire mal allez on fait mal à wesley
et on remonte ff iv c'est lui qui veut
nous faire mal maintenant à lyon lui
fait mal d'amis six années c'est bien ça
c'est une menace par les menaces cammas
est assez manière assez virulente wesley
donc c'est ag as.g qu'est ce qu'on fait
mais on fait peut-être un f aux menaces
quoi il fait fou détroit ça me fait
quand même un peu peur parce que le roi
noir est quand même faible les pièces
dont j'ai changé le fou g3 va être bien
je mets une éval d'ordi mais j'y crois
pas réel et l'ordi qui donne un avantage
blanc quand même on réussit pas à lui
faire mal et qui avait lieu cette baisse
qui a pas fou prend et dames g4 ok
pranger 3,6 sur un échec ça empêche de
faire d'amuser 5 sur échec ça va ça
tient dam des deux fous des trois pions
détroit est d'alger 6 allée maxime 7 et
position qui lui convienne mieux je dois
sûrement vouloir faire un dame f2 ou
quoi pour attaquer la contrôler sa
attaqué la cavale et t5
ça me prendrait quatre est ce que max a
quelque chose ici cavaliers trois tours
et si ça semble pas très bon mais il ya
ce petit truc attaché et il menace
peut-être tour des huit dames ces trois
cavaliers des 5
allez allez peut-être c'était le piège
là où est-ce là le piège est en train de
se refermer sur l'américain aller maxime
allais petit allez on y va on le
martyrisent est ce que fout au 5 et
jouable pour wesley réalité surtout
reprend dame prend kg 4 la dame f5 qui
touchera à tour fait tour alors attends
sur tour des huit c'est quoi le blem pro
cavalli ces deux oui mais il n'y a pas à
y a pas de même de il ya toujours eu un
il objet de faire dame ces trois dames
c3 est le seul coup et maximales
attendait temps d'attendre
ces trois étaient mes deux deuxièmes
meilleurs coûts d'après leurs dix dames
17 était une gaffe il ya eu du coup
prises en six prises en mach 1 dames 8 3
h 7
il va devoir revenir avec ses grandes
jambes vous faire rager 1 allée maxime
domine la pendule de soe mauvaise à les
cayes prend 1 dame prend b2 aller maxime
allais petit on remonte on remonte on
lui bouffe sont y en a trois et on va
lui faire les pieds avec le pion bea les
allées maxou allez allez il faut le faut
lui mettre la pression là elle sera
importante à gagner et vous voyez ça
joue à pas grand chose un des matches à
des partis en faveur de maxime qui ont
un peu mal tourné allez il faut y aller
il faut y aller moi qui viens manger ici
sales & max mon voile pion à wemmel
pions des qui va partir à la dame tête
en d4 qui va être un peu maître du jeu a
laissé me réaction qui part mais il va
faire dame 17 ou dames cécile va bloquer
la montée du pion ça ne va pas suffire
mais c'est bien quand même le scénario
des parties est de nouveau bien pour
maxime qui essayent qui essayent qui
essayent là pour essayer qui est mal
autant maxime qui a raison de tenter au
f4 c'est bien joué il veut il veut aller
prendre le bus avec le roi allait au
forceps maxime g 4 3 3 a laissé bien des
quatre dames prend des quatre il peut
pas il a pas d'échec ques les allées
prend le pion petit aller petit à il va
la gagner salle elle va faire tourner le
match aller il fait tourner le match
maxime allez allez c'est bon et dames 5
leur tour et tu toucheras jamais au pion
à cinq ou même peut-être un autre coup
un endroit les deux yatama de attention
mais les dames 5 on protège le pion est
on
on se débrouillera des échecs au f4 bien
jouer dame gk3 cinq dames g3 il est en
train de s'embrouiller wesley aller
maxime c'est hyper important de la
gagner celle-là il faut rapprocher le
roi du pion à 5 est allé se cacher après
avec la dame est envoyé deux pions on
peut y arriver à l'est c'est difficile
de jouer tempo quand tu fais affaire
échec échec a le temps qu'ils jouent en
ta faveur
il faut faire le taf il faut faire le
taf maxime leroy qui va réussir à se
cacher et ouest et qui va suer à grosses
gouttes
sans oublier qu'un jour en mettant une
dame sur la première on peut on peut
faire un contre échec
ça m'a l'air cool tout ça à roye b deux
dames eux deux est roi c'est un an est
roi c'est un je crois qu'il est plus
d'échecs
c'est bien qu'ils puissent jouer un peu
plus vite maxime tournicoti tournicoton
pour le moment c'est bien c'est bien ça
il n'ya plus d'échecs
allez on a un répit dames 1 dames 5
yes yes we petit oui petit oui petit
c'est ça qu'on veut voir c'est ça qu'on
veut voir les amis c'est ça qu'on veut
voir
et allez les amis on a gagné il a
progressé il a gagné il a fait l'échec
il à tout prix aller moins 5
on remonte à cesson qui sent le souffle
de maxime revenir aller l'italienne la
maxime il est pas content il est énervé
allez allez allez il faut encore la
reprendre c'est la revenir revenir à
quatre points ou wesley qui fait la
gueule il souffre ici il souffre on le
voit souffrira les maximes on continue
on remonte elle à tout était encore
possible 5 points on sent le français
qui commença
le devant il faut juste continuer il a
mis du temps à se chauffer maintenant il
va falloir il va falloir leur faire
payer au prix fort à l'américain son
insolence d'avoir voulu prendre sept
points d'avancé en début de match aller
maxime on y va on continue on gagne on
ne se laisse pas faire aller en france
est toujours dans le match avec sa
petite italienne qui sont partis à
angers 6 f 6 max qui va être en
confiance en plus y'a le bullet qui
arrive derrière le match n'est pas plié
loin de là loin de là les amis ouais
c'est qui va qui va apprendre qui va
apprendre le respect ce soir ça sera pas
faire on lâchera pas les faire ouais non
sookie qui rit un peu jaune je dirais
sourire un peu vrai mais il fait un peu
la soupe à la grimace
le joueur le joueur philippe un
américano philippins il boit un peu
d'eau maintenant mais c'est pas ça qui
va le remettre en forme
maxime qui a mangé à fond en début de
match et maintenant qui va y aller à les
pollutions et symétrique
mais maxime qui maîtrise bien mais tous
les tours sur les colonnes d au pire ça
fait une nul insipide et ce sera pas
grave c'est maxime qui veulent réussir à
faire cavalli c4 et à s'en prendre aux
pions au 5 allée c'est bien très belle
brune autres adam et j'y crois à 10% là
écoute la remonte à la est en route en
tout cas la remonte à da est en route
maxime qui peut qui peut le faire kiffer
b4 prend l'espace dam des trois c'est
bien ils contrôlent la colonne des
continue à mettre la pression un peu sur
cinq cavaliers en e3 bien placé
cavaliers angers 6 qui est un petit peu
éteint et c'est là un peu le moment
difficile maintenant pour réussir à
faire des progrès parce que ouais ses
amis une ligne maginot en face et ses 5
îles ferme b6 puis on prend hélas il a
dû voir quelque chose cavalier qui
arrive en f5 en elle c'est bien ça c'est
bien joué de la part de maxime
ce cavalier adverse peut pas peut pas
faire la même chose et donc il a un
cavalier f5 contre un cavalier g6 qui
peut pas bouger cavaliers apsys qui ne
peut pas lui venir en aide
mais le problème c'est que ça reste très
solide pour wesley peut-être un petit
coup droit g2 histoire de s'éviter de
prendre un échec non cavaliers des 6
maxime belliqueux qui fait une double
attaque ou maxime qui fait une double
attaque
on l'avait pas vu le pion b5 wesley qui
est en train de prendre l'eau ouais
c'est qui est en train de prendre l'eau
et il va devoir jouer la finale qui doit
être nul malheureusement après dame
prend 2,4 les changements de 4 et la
prison le 5 mai sera quand même une
finale pénible à défendant il fait dames
cette dame prend 4 juste vérifier
c'était faisable ou pas aïe avec cavalli
g5 pardon c'était le piège du joueur
français
ah ouais non donc la maxime qui a une
grosse domination maintenant aller maxou
faut aller du coup fait le pion aux 5
il commence par wager deux bons pour
défendre le plan à trois il va falloir
réussir à bouffer au 5 allée à 6 gagne
on vient à moins 4 allez on prend 1,5 et
orion le farsi
et farsi ouest gso ya rien cavalli f4
cdu c'est du vent froid g3 et on va te
bouffe et ont cavalé f4 et il te restera
plus que les yeux pour pleurer
voilà il fait il fait voilà c'est la
partie ouest et sow qui va pouvoir
abandonner on revient à quatre points
ouais c'est sow qui en train de sentir
la puissance française
il se prend du gérard depardieu dans la
gueule ça fait très mal
il a rien un cavalier car elle est là où
pierre cavalié g1 ils abandonnent
ils abandonnent ou est ce les sauts plus
que quatre points d'écart les amis on
est de retour
le joueur américain qui craque et ça va
être le retour de la nage dans ce nom on
continue on change pas une équipe qui
gagne on repart dans la time and affalé
gérard il est il en train de craquer ou
est ce là il est en train de craquer il
comprend tout à fait si en train de se
passer il sait que son adversaire est
français et il sent il sent la
différence
allez on y croit les amis on y croit on
est tous derrière maxime on est à fond
et ouest et sow qui a quasiment il a qui
donne à lula robert s j'ai envie de te
dire c'est la s c'est là c'est là c'est
la rs ouais c'est la s pour progresser
at il vraiment envie d'avoir des
supporters de ce calibre alors on y va
position
position équilibrée les blancs qui ont
la peur de fou mais c'est du vent allez
maxime allais il joue plus vite
rares ont en bullet est-ce que sow va
pouvoir résister aux français il est
parti pour une re montade à maxime là on
est parti pour la remonte à la cedh
dommage qu'il ait perdu autant de
parties en cinq puissant tout à l'heure
il en a donné 2 3 à la fin où il aurait
pu juste prendre du temps et laisser le
temps passe et il serait déjà rien qu à
moins un
on le sent quand même plus fort alors
attention en rester là à quoi ils
pensent et ce qu'il serait pas en train
de penser un flash 7 damage cinq tours d
un qui pourrait faire mal mais y'aura
cavalière trois échecs je pense enfin
deux variantes et ça va aller pour
maxime allais max tel le roseau plie
mais ne rompt pas et partick watson mon
roi prend c'est plus ou moins forcée
d'un match 5 tours d un ça va partir roi
g8 tempo c'est le seul coup autour d un
boisé qui laisse un peu de suspense mais
il le joue emma ivoire quoi cavaliers f3
échec
non mais juste après 9,3 sur c'est quoi
c'est quoi le coup là pour maxime
cavaliers t3 rey et du coût d'un brand
et 5 et tout reprend détroit et elle
donne quoi cette finale ouais bon il ya
un pion de moins mais c'est fou de
couleurs opposées ça va faire nul a
laissé bien max avec les noirs qui
résistent bien c'est bien joué c'est
bien joué maxime qui reste dedans
il est toujours bien quatre points
d'écart il va reprendre les blancs c'est
là il va pas la perdre de toute façon
puis on passe et qui fait pas mal
il faudrait juste mettre les trucs sur
blanc comme il faut faire à cinq à
quatre baies 5 et mettre le fou en ces
cas pour tous tenir et le roi qui défend
le pion le pion de l'autre côté
donc je pense à cinq à quatre baies 5
pouces est la bonne technique
évidemment je vais pas prendre les
finales à maxime plutôt moi qui suis
content d'eux
d'avoir la bonne technique de nul et
après on défend de l'autre côté et ont
fait nul tranquillement tous les pions
pour être protégé par le fou c'est
exactement ce qu'on cherche là c'est
exactement ce qui fait ça va faire nul
tranquillement wesley qui se noie ça
c'est nul tranquille on va pouvoir
reprendre nos esprits à rien n'a plus
rien à voir dans cette partie ça c'est
bon j'ai mw sow qui va faire nul
allez je paie soit qui devrait vous
étiez défaitiste dans le tchat
vous croyez pas entre entrant notre
maxime nationale non je pense qu'il va
la gagner dans les bulles est maxime je
suis très confiant la prépa forêt qu'ils
puissent remonter à -3 dans le iii +1 et
finir le tape dans le bullet après
wesley là il fait tourner la monde
peut-être il sent qu'il sent qu'il faut
jouer la montre et cela comprend la
nature du problème ils jouent contre
plus fort que lui
mais il comprend la nature du problème
qui est que maxime ils jouent ils jouent
la montre là un petit peu après j là il
a le droit et là comme une meilleure
position tall oil on peut essayer ya
rien de scandaleux mais clairement ils
veulent il a émis la raison il a raison
peut pas on peut pas critiquer ou est ce
les qui est dans le dur qui fait ce que
maxime aurait dû faire tout à l'heure au
lieu de au lieu d'enchaîner les parties
de tilter de et de donner des points
maxime aurait dû faire ça un prendre
prendre le temps
et laisser voilà faire un peu tourner la
formule il va faire des cinq ça reste
complètement nul mais il a il a tout à
fait raison et cela ça va lui faire
tourner de trois minutes ça lui permet
de récupérer ses esprits sans l'avoir
peut-être une partie en trois plus un
c'est bien joué c'est de la gestion de
match foppa faut pas critiquer ça faut
savoir gérer les matches et là c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt bien joué de la part
de sow qui n'a pas fait un plus tôt dans
le match mais la voilà c'est un petit
peu de gestion et il n'y a pas de y'a
pas de mauvais esprit là dessus c'est
tout à fait normal si tu veux pas contre
le fasse il faut être devant c'est tout
il n'ya pas y'a pas un sourcil et
surtout qui pressent un peu way sli fait
vraiment quelque chose dans cette partie
il fait vraiment quelque chose c'est à
dire que là il crée vraiment des menaces
fou prend h5 ya roi prend fin le 8 le
retour 3 et 6 kva ils essayent de la
gagner c'est pas que je joue des coûts
vide c'est qu'il va peut-être l'arnaqué
d'ailleurs maxime qui pensaient comme
nous qu'il est en totale gestion et
l'ordinateur de plus 14 victoires de
wesley so incroyable comment maxime a pu
perdre ça c'est incroyable
il y avait trois baies 6-3 6-7 qui
arrivait et c'était fini oh là là une
défaite de débutants incroyable de
s'être laissé piéger
ah qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué de la
part de wesley voyez les rois v6 3 7
c'était fini ah ouais c qui a fait
semblant qui jouait la montre et qui a
et qui a tenté une idée avec ap cinq des
5 maxime qui a petit qui a eu un allah
qui a eu une saute de concentration qui
a pas qui a pas été méfiant là dessus oh
là là là là quelle catastrophe
les amis celle là elle fait mal hein
il s'est laissé endormir par wesley qui
étaient là tapi dans l'ombre
oh là là j'en reviens pas c'est une
position qui qui est tellement nulle
tellement simple à jouer qui n'a pas
fait attention maxime c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable aie
fait mal celle là elle fait mal
elle fait mal parce que tu fais est nul
les yeux fermés il était tellement malin
ou est ce les halls à la salle elle fait
mal mentalement parce qu'on vient à -4
et sow qui est vrai en plus il a laissé
de perdre tournée de la pendule du coup
elle fait vraiment mal cela allait faut
s'accrocher maxime mais ça c'est
suffisait juste de mettre le fou sur les
bonnes cases en fait ne pas laisser
faire ça et de faire plus attention
après d'être plus vigilants fou qui est
reparti vers ie8 je sais pas ça devait
pas être très sorcier mais sow qui a
trouvé à qui a trouvé un moyen
oui les ruses et ouais mais c'est quand
même ça l'aude endormir comme ça ou non
en fait un tas france a alors y'a pas
y'a pas à 6 en l'air bouffées bouffe à 6
on t'apprend ça avec les vieilles
parties de boules vinik déjà d'endormir
son adversaire c'est une très bonne
stratégie très connu mais la maxima pas
été assez vigilant bon là ça va aller ça
valait maxime qui se reprend tout de
suite et qui va essayer de revenir à -4
aller direct mac se recolle au score
allez faut recoller à quatre points
trois points il peut le faire en bulles
est allé max allez allez voir ça ça là
il peut la gagner il faut la gagner tout
de suite se remettre dans le match
il en restera une en trois puissants
derrière donc il va avoir ou peut-être
même deux mais peut avoir le temps de
passer à plus 4 voire même plus 3 côté
saut simplement aller pour coller
recoller recoller il reste six minutes 9
minutes une partie dure six salavat dure
encore aurait plus de deux minutes
normalement il y en a encore deux mais
pour le moment il pourra juste ce
regretté sont-ils tin tin qui dit je
pense qu'on va augmenter son niveau
ouais ouais ce lait qui joue bien et là
l'idée c'est que le 3 contre 1 il va
faire mal hein alors là bon courage à
l'ouest et pour défendre tour qui peut
passer en déça attention cavaliers ne
peut-être jusqu'au f2 alors on colmate à
mes cavaliers des cinq salles et wesley
qui commence ses petits trucs là il est
bon pour ça peut-être juste tour d2
alors à mes qualités 5 quand même ouais
mais maintenant il va voir tour c'est 8
c'est bien joué allez maxime qui envoie
la calèche et qui va envoyer les pions
aller max il faut réussir à les faire
passer ses pions tu peux le faire
tour à tour leurs baies 5 tours à quatre
baies six tours à deux tours b 2 donc il
faut faire un cinq cavaliers c7
peut-être qui va arriver
ouais suroît 8 à 6 années maxime tu la
gagnes c'est là a bien joué sauf qu' on
voit le contre jeu de l'autre côté
alors là il faut voir ce tour à deux
tours j'ai deux heures ouais c'est très
bien joué de la part de wesley et le h5
h4 la très bien joué allez le truc c'est
que tour à 2 3 b 3 tours j'ai 2 à 6 h 3
à 7 h 2a huit dames web et cattrall et
c'est bien là ce que fait max faut faire
gaffe à pas soit 1 tourcoing f3 russie à
un moment donné mais ça m'a pas l'air
d'être trop dangereux allez faut la
gagner ça la maxe on propose que ces
trois dans le chat qui était une vraie
option à mon avis et ses trois tours 1
peut-être mais 5 sera 7 3 des 6 alors
est ce qui peut faire b6 roi prend des
cinq baies cette jeune pense que b6
gagne c'est pas trop comment ça s'est
passé mais je pense que ça gagne mais sa
santé les deux pions était trop fort
allez max qui va revenir là il revient à
quatre points c'est beau ça il a
vraiment pris le dessus sur son
adversaire
c'est qui fait la gueule il est dans le
mal
il restera il restera une partie dans la
cadence ouais c'est qui fait la gueule à
fond
et oui parce que s'y prend à 6 je n'ai
pas noté meilhat bessette et le cavalier
impérial il contrôle p 6 et 7 blessés il
fera sûrement tour c'est ce tour b 6 3
c'est cette prendra et serra de la jouer
quand même alors là sur bessette yves
leroy dessin qu'on pourra faire à 7
bon ça va un peu joué encore mais de
façon ça change rien pour la pendule
parce qu'il ya est ce qu'une partie
derrière donc là il n'ya pas y'a pas il
n'y a pas vraiment de différence à ce
que wesley la joue pas de toute façon on
va on va aller dans la dernière après il
y aura plus de cinq minutes c'est sûr
maxime qui fait cavalier b4 alors il
veut arriver encore plus droit 17 laisse
le roi revenir j'ai dû rater quelque
chose tout à l'heure on va venir ans et
8 j'imagine
et l'on voit g5
il veut être 5 g 4 h 3 couvre la
varroase 6 avec l'idée paroisse et six
tours c'est un tour à pied ses six tours
b un f5 maintenant allez ça va aller là
ce qui doit refaire tour b 1
et ouais ça gagne ouest et sow qui est
tombé allez c'est reparti on y va à
l'essai gagner c'est bien joué allez
allez maxime wesley qui est qui et dans
le mal allez max encore une encore une
au moins une nuit là faut pas la perdre
s'ils gagnent ces bonus
je pense qu'il va y va arrive à remonter
c'est vraiment bête hein la partie là
qu'il a perdu et qu'il pourrait déjà
être à trois points ouais je pense que
mike valade tout misé en bullet je suis
d'accord avec monsieur p soit je donne
pas cher de la peau de notre ami ou à
orléans bull est la suivante
assez moderne lacarrau kanoute envoie
une pure h comme ça un peu en vadrouille
or comme on continue à cela mais il doit
se poser beaucoup de questions et ce qui
fait grand roc ou est ce qu'il fait
petit rock je pense corps et cela du mal
parce qu'il sait plus ce qu'il doit
faire et ce qu'il doit gérer la hesse
qui doit gérer le match et s'il doit
jouer pour la gagne je pense que wes
lail à un moment vraiment difficile on
va voir si si c'est un grand joueur s'il
réussit à se remettre
parce que là les conditions sont
vraiment défavorables marc faire dam des
deux cavaliers g6 allait peut-être tour
à 20 tours f1 pourquoi pas sinon
arbitres derrière eux je pense pas à la
séjour à la non je pense pas qu'il soit
dans la zone des joueurs soupçonnés
je suis se voir le match pour comprendre
que tout est absolument normal mais il
peut arriver parfois qu'ils les joueurs
soient soupçonnés qui est un acquis en
armes derrière eux ça arrive près une
fois je connais les noms des fois non
mais je peux pas pas vous divulguer ces
informations
nice qu'un blizzard qui une telle
différence de niveau entre 5 +13 plus
simple non c'est une question de
confiance
c'est comme si tu regarde un match de
tennis qui est un mec qui fait deux
breaks mène 4 0 en moins et qui se fait
remonter et tu as et enfin c'est pas
bizarre c'est le haut niveau c'est comme
ça maxime qui était pas en confiance qui
souffrait il a gagné une partie sale a
décoincé et maintenant et maintenant ça
se passe bien
alors là il va devoir aller avec flash
deux échecs 3 h 1 houphouet fuite
peut-être plutôt fuite par envie d'aller
s'embêter avec le fou là bas
la position qui est de nouveau
incertaine c'est un peu d'un côté un
pion des quatre qui a un peu fait de
l'autre côté il ya le foie fille qui a
du mal à jouer et aller encore une
tactique il ya tout qui rentre là à
wesley qui est vraiment dans le malin il
ya tout qui passe
la petite halle à petit le petit fou
prend ses cinq le petit couloir il a
peut-être dame prend à 5 encore pour
pour exister il n'avait pas vu l'un je
fais pareil doit y avoir une raison
il veut a oui ok il veut à l'effet a
joué là nul dans la dans la [ __ ]
couleur opposée parce que le cad v 3 de
ce côté là et pas très impressionnant il
veut tour à 4 maintenant pour aller s'en
prendre option à 5 c'est malin ce que
fait ouest est une nouvelle fois c'est
un peu le point fort de wesley c'est que
même quand il rate on a vu eux on a vu
maxime quand tu iras tu es qui vraiment
glissé complètement ouais c'est lui
réussit à être stable à s'accrocher même
quand ça se passe pas bien il reste là
tapi tapis dans l'ombre
c'est vraiment son point fort donc là
c'est vraiment la d re partie où est le
temps en dessous de l'échiquier qui
s'égrènent les secondes qui passe
signifie la fin du segment 2 3 + 1 donc
à la fin de cette partie on aura droit à
une nouvelle pause et maxime qui
tournera j'ai envie de dire aux pires
anormalement bas je ne crois pas peur à
-4 et donc tout est faisable
tout est possible ça vous apprendra être
défaitiste par contre là l'idée tour à
quatre coups des deux ça parait dur
empêcher j'imagine que la partie va
solder par une nulle mais on va pouvoir
le faire il va pouvoir le faire on va
avoir une session de bullet de folie les
makes ne parte et surtout pas la
dernière demi heure va être va être
magnifique
ça va être ça va être ça va être très
tendu
ça va être ça va être beau à voir
tout et tout est encore faisable what's
he saw qui évidemment est quatre points
d'avancé quand même favori mais vu ce
qui se passe du les tactiques vu le jeu
de maxime il peut il peut revenir
il peut revenir c'est de se faire un
pion à se passer mais ça devrait solder
par une nulle comme condition à leur
strict des commentaires on verra
et c'est même de la gagne et maxime
assez bien joué il veut faire tours fc
tfk il va peut-être même revenir à 3
points
s'il ya un mais pions prend pions prend
tout rêve c'est 3 g iii f4 direct il va
prendre ici roy h35 il va essayer de
faire passer ou est allé maxime il fait
souffrir sorin il va faire bref 5 3 à 4
tours g7 je pense ça fait pas suffire
tout cas mso sous pression et fait juste
tourache entourage cette fois ci c'est
chaque croyant 5-fu des 5
faut réfléchir comment passer de la
bonne manière
bref ça qui va laisser la tour venir en
d6 mais il peut éventuellement remettre
simplement le fou en d5 mes droits
reviendront en h3 ça va être compliqué
mais maxime peut peut le faire les
remous en d5 et tour g7 pour commencer
il va le faire craquer sow qui va
craquer une nouvelle fois il peut
peut-être faire rager quatre là au
prochain il va remettre le fonds
investit dans tour g1 ah oui le fou qui
va avoir piétinent à plus de cases food
et de il va faire tour il va faire 3
faut prendre trois tours j'ai trois
tours prend 2,3 allez ça va faire plus 3
à ces magnifiques alley maxime allais
petit il est remonté les amis à
sautillant peu plus fou des 2 3 c'était
fini vous prend et trois tours j'ai
trois échecs il a trois points et merci
pour pour le surf sur match est persuadé
du coup et et la petite intervention de
vlad au passage il faut trois tours h un
match encore plus fort mais bon de toute
façon tour 3 à tout retour j'ai trois
tours droit ça va ça vient laurent crécq
richet dans le chai dans le chat c'est
le cas allez allez les mecs ils restent
ariès kouassi minutes n'hésitez pas à
faire un petit pas ce partage sur
twitter je vais je vais mettre un petit
tweet allez on fait peut-être même pas
de pause là il ya bien trop d'enjeu il
ya trop de trucs peut-être ont fait pas
causants je suis obligé de mettre une
pub quand même aph
comment je peux faire le castor avec la
pub
comment risquer de perdre son job avec
chaque point comme pour faire plaisir
aux oreilles
allez je mets deux minutes de pub et je
fais un petit tweet
je me réjouis très le lien pour partager
alors allez être pévèle à inquiéter qui
deux mois 7 revient à -3 dans son match
pour wesley so avant la section bullet
je met un petit jeu étaient des petits
mails qui sourit je vais mettre dans le
moule est à noter mode je met quoi je
suis en train de choisir mais émeutes
les modes qui marche pas je lis plus le
chat et les mecs fait un petit tweet
pour pour que vous puissiez partager
mais il faut les bons émeutes
allez je vais mettre le lien du switch
aller c'est beau la sq est en train de
se passer
allez je mets le tweet je vais je vais
être le truc pour que vous puissiez
partager du cou qui hélas annonce un max
de partage là pour la fin c'est quand
même hein c'est quand même une belle une
belle fin de match donc je vous ai mis
le petit tweet
les pubs qui sont là et maxime qui est
remonté à fond et partage à fond si vous
avez fait vous pouvez aussi mettre un
petit facebook mais c'est peut-être plus
un truc twitter qu'elle est max de
partage max de like pour celui là là on
va vivre un beau moment d'échec
ça va être très très très sympa là ça va
être vraiment le feu ça va être le feu
là à cette fin de match ça va être le
feu total
ça va être fantastique tout cas on est
bien mais beaucoup de beaucoup de
spectateurs aujourd'hui on est encore
1300 on n'a pas la première page depuis
très longtemps donc c'est cool
vous suivez à fond cette compétition et
j'en profite pour vous pour vous en
remercier ça fait évidemment très
plaisir de vous voir si nombreux suivre
suivre cette compétition aujourd'hui a
vraiment pas eu une grosse première page
mais a beaucoup de de gens qui viennent
qui suivent
si vous aimez
n'hésitez pas à follow la chaîne faut
aussi follow ma chaîne perso vous avez
des liens juste en dessous
donc il ya le fameux bataille qui va tu
vas qui va commencer à rêver ça c'est
vous c'est cameco plus sinon le fameux
matin il commence déjà le fameux battle
ou pas je pense pas que ce soit en même
temps en en j'espère en tout cas ils ont
tous mis la pub de partout sur toutes
les chaînes on va rester en direct on va
pas s'embêter way femme fatale c'est fou
quoi
c'est fou je viens un peu ce que font
les autres bons jeux pas trop parler
pendant la pause que je vais beaucoup
parlé après les puzzles pas talent c'est
quoi la position sera une propulsion de
puzzle rush
le fameux papale c'est fou quoi c'est
fou parce que vous avez partagé sur
twitter ou pas on va voir on va voir si
vous êtes des bons non mais ça abusé
vraiment rien sur twitter sur 1300
personnes on a 16 like et de retweets
fin franchement les mecs
ben non mais vraiment quoi enfin je sais
pas mais si vous voulez qu'un jour que
les échecs se soit plus regardées faut
se bouger le fion sur les réseaux 1
je le dis déjà sur sur mes vidéos avec
les pouces bleus les commentaires les
machins vous bougez pas le fion il ya
des événements on devrait avoir au moins
s'en sont jamais être entre tweet quoi
ce serait un minimum normalement en fait
mais je ne sais pas à rentrer dans le
21e siècle les mecs faut enfin faut
comprendre c'est important twitter les
réseaux et tout ça à face et c'est
vraiment important en réalité donc toute
façon moi le tweet en plus je vais
supprimer après le match enfin faut
comprendre que c'est faux que vous soyez
plus sur twitter quand je vais jouer je
vais venir faire des conférences dans
des clubs je vous engueuler je vous
défoncer c'est important quoi là c'est
dur mais dans un stade c'est dur a
partagé avec l'ordi et tout mais twitter
c'est bien pour ce genre de chose pour
les partager tout ça c'est bien un
twitter c'est mieux que facebook twitter
de façon tu twittes tu retweet crois tu
as là ok j'en parle un peu on est monté
à 27 j'aime 27 retweet on peut on peut
faire mieux quand même
non ma personne sur twitter faut que tu
fasses et des tweets enfin faut faire du
tweet marguerite il dit c'est que quand
tu évoques autour de toi que tu poses
déjà qu'on prend pour un homme du xviiie
non c'est pas vrai les échecs c'est
light un ca et peu les échecs il ya plus
deux ans qui suivent les en français a
de plus en plus de gens qui suivent les
échecs sur twitter il faut le savoir sur
twitter et sur twitter aussi du coup
mathieu on a 19 voix franchement on
pourrait monter à 100 like si on avait
si vous étiez plus chauds sur les
réseaux genre mais un lien pour ceux qui
l'ont raté
je l'aï tout le temps et j'avais des
comme sur télé vidéo mais les retweets
et chaud j'ai peur de passer pour un non
mais avec les bacs franchement t'as vu
je suis marié avec une fille qui est
quand même huit et demi c'est quand même
suivre est mariée qu'une vite et demi en
étant joueur d'échecs
tu vois en faisant des échecs mon métier
tu vas donc j'ai envie de te dire c'est
pas rédhibitoire pivot - au moins un
like sur le tweet on va pas passer on va
pas aller jusqu'au 28 mo - like soir qu'
un peu de gens qui suivent qui voit là
ça va être ça va être un beau truc
maxime ambühl est une demi-heure et ou
non mais vraiment un
combien d'années de mariage ça l'année
prochaine si je vais fêter les 10 ans de
mariage
no fake enfin je pourrai prouver le no
fake et mon livret de famille mais je
vais pas le faire parce qu'il ya des
informations confidentielles
mais le no fait que pourrait être enfin
les enfants je me suis refait surtout
mai date de naissance tous mes trucs
mais je pourrai prouver le no fake au
cas où
c'est quelqu'un qui veut venir me voir
et me dire montre moi le no fake que je
peux prouver le no fake
voilà vous un peu 43e 24 tweet c'est ce
qu'on devrait avoir à chaque fois
donc du coup je peux prouver nos facs ça
lui en fait nan mais quand et à cannes
lui dis que j'aurais plus de prouver le
no fake je vais pas prendre mon livret
de famille avec moi les mecs arrêtez
quoi ça craquait alors ça va reprendre
très bientôt
c'est la pause les joueurs se reposent
quel est mon joueur préféré on va dire
talent puisqu'il est le même jour que
vlad
ouais je suis marié rennes du coup et
c'est pour dire qu'on peut on peut
partager des échecs et être marié moi je
met sur les deux chats parce que j'ai
pas mis sur les deux chat
allez on va se battre à fond des cages
et 32 ans
non je les fais pas maintenant je suis
plus jeune que mon âge faut le savoir
donc 3 2 en fait non et je peux te
montrer en livret de famille pour
prouver le no fake
s'il est ici si tu les fais donc voilà
j'attendais il faut que je mette aussi
ce que j'avais pas mis le lien de
partout je n'ai pas mis sur le chat de
youtube
c'est chose faite pour que les gens qui
suivent sur youtube puis aussi a aussi
heurté alors du coup est ce que risque
on a beaucoup de retweets ou pas et j'ai
pas âgées pas j'ai pas de permis de j'ai
pas de permis voiture faut que je le
passe j'avais prévu de le passer cette
année mais j'ai trop de choses à faire
allez c'est reparti les amis c'est
reparti pour le mulet talent et les amis
maxime défonce le défonceuse aller une
italienne il est parti boom p 4 il
envoie un pion dans sa gueule le gambit
even ces trois lieux attaques sont fous
allez on y va des quatre il prend le
centre il va tout envoyé à la paul
murphy toi t'es nul moi je m'appelle
paul murphy
c'est ça qu'on veut voir c'est ça qu'on
veut voir des ouvertures à l'ancienne
des attaques sur le roi de la
victimisation de wesley so petit rock
peut-être cavaliers g5 damage saint
calais on lui envoie tout dessus
est-ce que cavalli g5 déjà s'est joué à
brocade à mach 5 tu te fais maths est
allée ouest et qu'est ce que tu fais il
est même à oissel inquiet déjà rouge
habite bat aby tulle par roc dames h5
matt de greco c'était déjà assez
existait des gens c'est 100 et la dame
f3 pas piquée des hannetons va tous
menacés ou sso qui va prendre la porte
là dans la première partie à mon avis
d'un beffroi ça fait mal
il ya peut-être d'autres choses
cavaliers problème cette dame f3 un peu
comme si l'appel est fléché gâté lola
les frei deliver rouaroua roi aux six
dames 4 et sur dame et fils beau monde
fait péter ton cavale foule si ce fou
prend aussi cédé 5 échecs qui fera une
fourchette ou est ce les sauts qui prend
l'eau foix iii on va te prendre de
l'autre côté à rebrousse poil il fait
dames 4 c'est très bien aussi
et maintenant peut-être aller il faut il
faut quand même être sérieux là il faut
le finir à les maximes il faut le finir
il faut le frire il faut le frire la
dame termine en f3 peut-être dû dame g3
qui arrive ou g5 à l'est d'alger 3 pour
mona disque
être manqué ses trois bien joué il se
place ça va arriver de partout à la le
petit dame g3 on va pas échanger les
dames sat inquiète pas ça va bien se
passer un bien bien se passer
le cavalier qui va pouvoir jaillir en 1
4 il ya ça arrive de partout s les sauts
qui va perdre et maxime qui va revenir à
moins de maxime qui est qui est bien
partie à des fouilles f4 ont lu attaque
saddam peut aussi commencer par fou j'ai
cinq échecs mais fou avec 4 paraît bien
et on va placer les tours sur la colonne
colonnes on va préparer fougier 5-fu
aussi la tour en d1 alors là c'est la
cata pour wesley il se prend toutes les
pièces blanches dessus ils essayent de
résister il est mal autant et quoique
comprend déjà son malheur le joueur
américain
il comprend son malheur il défend bien
quand même
mais là les fous sont de sortie et on va
menacer attention de pas se prendre un
bateau un mais on va menacer un peu de
tout mais peut-être un damage quatre
échecs intermédiaire attention peut-être
fou c4 juste couvre la case f1 comme ça
on menace vraiment fou prend des 4 et
wesley qui va se prendre d'un match 4
échecs et surtout à 6 tours prend 17 c
sur échec et donc le joueur philippe un
tampon des cet échec
hélas ces dames de plus nette je vous le
dis tout de suite c'est fini maxime il
va pas la rater celle là et ça va faire
un point deux points d'écart on voit
quand même la différence de niveau 1 de
maxime qu'anti d'anti l'élève un peu le
ton quand ils comptent ils lèvent quand
il élève un peu le débat on voit quand
même que maxime a un talent qui est qui
est incroyable c'est vraiment un
vraiment un monstre ce maxime un joueur
d'exception qu'on a la chance d'avoir
alors là il se met à sacrifier mais
ouais elle à la tour de west et qui va
plus bouger allez prends encore un pion
et il va envoyer f et g
voici qui réussit à faire durer cette
partie plus plus qu'elle n'aurait dû il
ya peut-être faire flouer 4 pour la
menace discrète tourbe et en maths mais
sa maxime y va le voir aller là de la
casse est inquiet protégés allaient f4 h
4 h 5 ha et il faut finir vous essayez
plus vite possible après il a quand même
le temps en revenant à moins de il a
quand même le temps de revenir il est
pas pressé pressé
ouais c'est qui fait qui fait tourner le
chrono qui fait tourner les coûts pour
se remettre dedans mais maxime qui va
l'emporter g5 g6 h7
et ça va filer tout seul wesley qui vont
là qui exagère peut-être un peu aller
prendre la tour
ah non il veut vraiment la jouer comme
ça bon à mon avis va énerver notre
maxime allais meta d'amendé cinq ans
voilà dames et damas trois matches aller
il va il va nous énerver le maximal et
mac s'énerve toi frappé le allez
maintenant tu le feras ptu le défonce tu
lui en mai une deuxième année la petite
brune fait de la sai et maxime kahn ont
ils fait une narine est indienne mais là
et repart il va repartir sur du
répertoire de bullet et il va faire
souffrir le joueur américain qui va
avoir les 25 minutes les plus longues de
sa vie à passer et il fait d'ailleurs la
variante des changes de l'est indienne
pleutre pleutre il et pleutre wesley so
il se sent obligé de de serrer la vis et
de et de jouer une position très très
très calme finalement avec moins de
pièces sur l'échiquier parce qu'il a
peur il a peur du joueur français qui
est en train de revenir à toute blinde
e-menaces cavaliers prend 1,4 maxime il
menace qui est presque acquis et défendu
cavaliers aussi s'ils menacent le fou g5
le plomb f4 qui est mal il ya peut-être
du cavalier e 5 qui va rester en prise
par la suite pour le moment où est celui
qui réussit à tout défendre mais c'est
que partie remise cavaliers des quatre
on s'en prend aux fouets f3 le fou plan
qui va venir aussi s'il va lui envoyer
b5 dans la gueule ça va pas va pas bien
se passer pour wesley eux cinq ils veut
fermer le jeu iphone 4 il est dans le
bon tempo
mais le fou qui vit à angers 4 la tour
en des huit ça va faire mal
ça va faire mal pour le moment c'est
qu'il ya un pion de plus mais mais
maxime qui joue très vite 28 secondes
avance et la position qui est voué à
s'ouvrir pour les fous b3 alors là il a
fait bien encore plus les cases noires
mais pour le moment le cavalier fait le
boulot
f5 chasse le fou sur le si le fort recul
on va simplement l'encaissé et surprise
qu on prend fou
bon et maintenant ça va bien se passer
sur cette diagonale cavaliers prend b3
qui on prend b3 fou prend ces trois
menaces latour menace le fou on va
encaisser le fougueux 4 et on va se
retrouver avec une égalité matérielle
mais c'est maxime qui va donner le la de
la position le fou en d4 est vraiment
dominant le fougueux 4 est en prise il
va faire un petit fou et trois échecs en
la huant mais aulas et ses salades
tomates oignons lasse et c'est partout
il ya le cavalier attaque et yann joseph
quatre ans prises il ya tour des quatre
ça gagne la pièce wes les sauts qui est
ça gagne pas la pièce mais presque
wesley so qui est vraiment dans le dur
il ya plongé 4 qui tombe il ya de fous
qui va revenir au f 6 olala il est en
train de se manger une une correction
wesley qui l'a pas vu depuis longtemps
maxime qui assure avec b6 m'attendais
plus à tourcoing il faut m6 mais ça va
très bien maxime qui va pouvoir mettre
une tour en g3 ou cas où
alors là il va prendre en d1 prendre g4
mais bon il a pions deux pions de plus
la position complètement gagnante
je vous rassure tout de suite maxime ne
va pas la laisser s'échapper celle là et
ça va faire plus qu'un point d'écart
attention attention wesley tu es en
train de glisser à wesley qui peut pas
mettre le carré long et 5 y avait un
clouage well as est là c'est assez
incroyable à maxime qui est à - 7 qui va
revenir à -1 et pour moi maintenant
c'est maxime qui est favori du match à
la vue à la vue du scénario on sent
maxime qui s'est tellement énervée là
s'il est vraiment vraiment passé devant
un miroir fca 3g trois rangées de on
n'en parle plus non il veut pas laisser
le con tre jeu il veut la gagner
tranquille ou est ce les de toute façon
qui est qui est pris n'est pas avoir g4
cuir wife 5 puis h4 aller le fait comme
ça avec le fond g3 et h4h 3 ça peut pas
revenir côté wesley et ça va faire ça à
faire un point d'écart
ce pas quand même wesley trouve quand
même des ressources
étonnamment le roi qui vas y vas prendre
le roi f1 à airois g3 et h2 et saddam
allez c'est gagner un point d'écart
plus de vingt minutes à jouer maxime qui
fait mal et on voit au langage corporel
que wesley est dans le dur et maxime
très malin
après le gambit events il change il joue
une anti berline une anti berlinoise
donc espagnol variantes de lentilles
berlin et wesley qui va qui a du mal là
il en peut plus aller maxime cavaliers
c4 on s'en prend aux pions au 5 et aux
fous il réussit à prendre la paire de
fouet celle là il va de nouveau la jouer
pendant des heures maxime qui est
vraiment bien on imagine un souvenir
aussi sous un f5 il va mettre la tour en
des huit pour rester là il faudrait
vraiment réussir à prendre une nulle et
à bam a fermé un peu la porte pour pour
arrêter l'hémorragie là parce que ça
fait ça fait beaucoup il a encore un
point d'avancé
il peut plus gérer il a peut-être
justement trop géré en 3 + 1 il a trop
pensé qu'ils avaient de la vence et
et qu'ils pouvaient gérer le le match à
sa main et c'était une grosse erreur
parce que quand maxime s'est remis en
mode maxime c'est ça fait mal et il a
senti passer à l'est dans cette position
est ce l'équipe pour le moment
s'accroche bien il a il a réussi à
garder son pion aux 5 à mettre un peu de
pression sur le pion de maxime en d3 là
maintenant il joue le clouage sur dame
eux deux il va pouvoir prendre en d3
probablement à moins qu'ils aient un
cavalier des cinq qui rôdent mais je ne
pense pas ou tour 8 ouais bien joué de
la part de wesley qui va tout est changé
et qui dans cette partie là hein mais un
poil devant il me semble en tout cas
c'est difficile d'analyser cette partie
comme don comme des enfants en analyse
ça comme un bullet on essaye de
comprendre quel est le joueur qui a la
position la plus pénible à défendre avec
peu de temps sur la pendule et on voit
bien que ici c'est maxime qui est un peu
en danger avec ce cavalier qui peut
jouer des tours qui peut venir en f3
attention max là il est dans le dur
maxime il faut là il faut il faut sauver
les meubles
et il faut défendre parce que wes les
menaces cavalier est royal fou emprise
et maxime qui abandonne rien à faire
white lies qui reprend du poil de la
bête à les matches il faut pas il faut
il faut retaper la faux pas à faut
passer ça va t il faut tout de suite
refaire mal c'est vrai qu'on l'a senti
ce cavalier cinq cavaliers trois échecs
qui arrivait et il y avait plus rien à
faire à les mac ce qui revient à sa nage
dorff
il n'a pas perdu tant il a abandonné
tout de suite il reste combien de temps
j'ai plus le temps sous les yeux et doit
rester une petite vingtaine de minutes
peut-être 19 minutes de jeu et on est
dans l'eau dans cette nage d'offres qui
convient terriblement à maxime
il va falloir revenir au score là encore
une fois même s'il restait dix minutes
de jeu
maxime pourrait encore remarqué de
points donc on n'est pas pressé ans
maxime qui n'est pas obligé de recoller
tout de suite du moment il fait nul y
gagne fait nul y gagner il est pas
il n'est pas dans l'urgence de points
d'écart ces deux victoires une partie
ces trois minutes trente temps qui reste
encore plus de cinq minutes à la pendule
il peut revenir donc il faut revenir à
sa main et c'est tout à fait ce qu'il
est en train de faire il est au courant
français et avec sa nage dorff là il est
en train de brouiller wesley il ya
cavaliers h ça que je crois qu'ils
attaquent la dame attaque g3 je sais pas
peut-être un truc sur cavaliers h5
j'avais l'impression que ça gagner parce
que là j'ai l'impression que celle
inverse et que c'est maxime qui perd une
pièce mais c'est très compliqué où il ya
du cavalier dessin qui en a de partout
il ya cavaliers ap six échecs qui rôde
là c'est une position compliquée au
possible il ya des tactiques des deux
côtés difficile de dire quel est le
joueur qui va sortir gagnant de la mêlée
mais il semble que moi c'est soit pas
mal et d'ailleurs maxime qui abandonne y
avait du fou pranger sept cavaliers f5
qui arrivait après je trouve l'abandon
un petit peu prématuré et wesley qui
revient à plus trois alors là vraiment
sensation côté côté américain wesley so
tête tête dans le seau qui remonte et
qui gagne deux parties maxime qui
finalement joue mieux en général mais il
est capable voilà de faire des cadeaux
ce que wesley ne fait pas et là il a
donné alors je pars me dire donner de
point mais il s'est hissé laisser un
petit peu grisés par par toutes ces
victoires et wesley qui est solide et
qui prend les points qu'ils ramassent à
les trois points d'écart à maxime peut
encore revenir
rien n'est fait cavaler des trois fous
j'ai deux on va s'en prendre aux pions
dessin à cal et max
il faut il faut gagner ce tion des 5 et
revenir là maintenant on est quand même
un peu plus dans l'urgence trois points
d'écart
dix sept minutes à jouer il faudrait
revenir comme je disais à -2 assez
rapidement pas rester dans ce territoire
de -3 à -4 c'est pas c'est pas là qu'on
veut être à l'essai une partie au long
cours qui s'annonce du fond du fond du
court c'est la terre battue ça va ça va
jouer longtemps les joueurs qui jouent
sur
qui maxime qui veut essayer de jouer
peut-être un jour sur le pion des cinq
sur les dames
wesley so qui a ramené beaucoup de
pièces lui de son côté allé droit mais
maxime qui est aussi très solide ça va
être difficile pour les deux joueurs de
percer les défenses mutuelle allez on va
essayer peut-être de faire un dame b 3 1
jour
essayez de taper un peu sur le pion b6
le pion des cinq allers l'aca échangeant
b4 alors à qui profite le crime j'ai
envie de dire dur dur à dire pour le
moment mais il semble wesley quand même
ce fou sans nouveau projet 5-fu pranger
ça qui on prend le car a lieu cinq
il semblait stratégiquement que maxime
était dans le dur mais il jouait plus
vite et il a réussi à placer la tactique
assez bien joué la position de wesley
s'écroule
la position du joueur américain qui
s'écroule puisqu'ils perdent deux pions
qui était très important dans son
système de jeu allait maxime celle là il
faut pas la rater revenir à plus de tout
de suite maintenant faire mal c'est ça
qu'on veut voir à les cavaliers g6 dame
f3 on propose les changes to rage de sa
marche pas parce qu'il ya cavaliers
prend et donc on va se jouer cette
finale qui est pas encore gagné mais
qu'il est quasiment quand même
ou est ce les qui va essayer de faire
durer un peu la partie parce que ça il a
raison il c'est maxime qui veut revenir
au score donc le temps qui s'égrène
c'est en faveur de wesley mais là
maintenant la tour de moins à il
récupère ses six mais hilare père il va
jouer jusqu'au bout on va en profiter
pour prendre une respiration maxime qui
va gagner la partie et qui va revenir à
deux points non ques les qui la joue
smith qui la jouent pas vraiment ça
puisqu'ils jouent tous tempo il se
laisse juste mater mais il attend pas le
temps à fond aller maxime qui repart
dans la neige d'or il reste 15 minutes
40 à jouer toujours deux points d'écart
on est toujours dans dans ce
dans ce réseau de points qu'on veut voir
alors maxime qui hésite il a hésité il
retourne dans la nage d'or et il venait
de perdre et ils jouent contre eux h3 le
coup j'ai si ça les fous j'essaie de
bouger de rock you ou trois cavaliers c6
savard hockey aussi côté blanc non il va
faire cavalier le 2 il va maintenir
l'écart et les enjeux food et 7 à 4 ils
empêchent tout contre eux jeu de l'autre
côté côté maxime donc ça va de nouveau
être ses positions en âge d'or où les
blancs ont réussi à prendre pas mal d
espace à l'ale allait droit mais maxime
qui envoie donc b5 et qui réussit à
contre attaquer à la dame au prix d'un
sacrifice de pions cavalli prend à cinq
cavaliers au sein qui s'activent
il va peut-être aller vers ces quatre le
four viendrait du coup vers la case
c'est un an il joue pouces et 6 il s'en
prend aux pions eu quatre cavaliers g3
est peut-être une option cavaliers
dessin qui est le coup choisi par wesley
dont qui défend le pion le fou qui
arrive en bessin qu'est-ce que rock est
jouable ou pas il va faire cavaler c4
sûrement il s'en prendre quand même à
beaucoup de choses donc b3 il empêche il
prépare ses quatre un coup comme damas
cinq dames des deux cavalières trois
fois froid ou c3 il y aura le cavalier
qui veillera mesdames des deux peut-être
dame un échec donc fou des deux dames à
cette maxime qui est en train de pêcher
en eaux troubles
il est moins bien il a un pion - mais
ils jouent une position qui lui convient
totalement bullet où il tente
il tente des tactiques quittant le clan
brouille née wesley so qui joue vite
maxime qui a envoyé une pièce il
envoyait une fois en c4 ça allait très
vite il joue avec une pièce de moi mais
en bordel pas possible sur l'échiquier
c'était peut-être un petit peu optimiste
quand même de la part du joueur français
mais bon il le sent il va faire tout
rachat suite il va faire tout rachat
suite il va aller jouer il va aller
jouer le match une proposition des
changes accepté par maxime qui
maintenant va jouer cette finale où il
veut récupérer un pion et obtenir et
obtenir la nulle part je vous ai dit
s'il reste à moins 2 ça va tout à fait
mais repartira -3 serait serait
dommageable
on va avoir quand même cette position
moi j'y crois maximy valette n'y arrive
à faire cavalier ces quatre cavaliers
detroit encore mieux jouer tour 2 qui
avait lieu 5
retour je pensais qu'il allait faire
cavalier c'est un lecavalier qui est
venu en f2 cavaliers c4 allez on va
essayer de taper un pion ça va être
difficile hein pourquoi ces sauts de
faire avancer faire avancer les pions
alors il avance un petit peu mais
maintenant il va falloir passer alors au
cinq il ya qu'il prend des cinq wesley
qui recule qui est client 17,5 il y
arrive
wesley là qui monte qui avance qui
avance qui avance et c'est un petit peu
comme au rugby là il va falloir il va
falloir un peu gagné les mêlées parce
que sinon la position va être père de
mickey et des troncs tend un piège c'est
pas très discret mais c'est une menace
pour wesley qui veut installer 4e 6
tours g8 au il se fait piéger ou est ce
les il se fait piéger
il se prend le clouage a bien joué
maxime qui ait réussi à récupérer un
pion alors après il va probablement
refaire des six mais il a réussi un
petit peu échangé f5 et c'est bien joué
bien jouer f5
il veut il veut tout est changé mais il
ya cavaliers qui va arriver en f6 aux
attentions sur cavaliers préemption
prend il veut peut-être installer des
réseaux de maths c'est dangereux alors
g5 qui va faire wife de menaces ou des 5
le roi qui va partir et partir partir
vers la tour et la tour qui va venir en
a cinq pour colmater à la foulée 5e ça
fait super peur
et ouais tour des huîtres ou des 5 vous
prend à deux aïe aïe aïe maxime qui est
qui qui a voulu jouer son jeu jouer leur
va-tout mais wesley qui a été d'une
solidité impressionnante en sept dents
dans cette position avec la pièce de
plus ça il a vraiment serré serré les
serrer les verrous il reste onze minutes
trois points d'écart il reste en gros
quatre parties à jouer c'est encore
faisable aller maxime négociée qui est
impressionnant bull est là après le
début de vue il est très difficile on
peut dire qu'il impressionne wesley
on s'attendait à le voir couler et il a
réussi mentalement a serré le jeu
il avait déjà été très étonnant l'année
précédente contre hikaru nakamura dans
cette même qu'à lens en bullet où on
voyait se faire dominer et où il avait
plus ou moins tenue avait quand même
perdu le match mais il avait opposé une
résistance incroyable
et là encore contre maxime il réalise
une performance un petit peu du même
acabit alors là il ya un bordel pas
possible la qualité cet échec
intermédiaire wesley qu'il a oublié et
il va la perdre parce que sur roy ici va
ya voir cahier des cinq pays france et
cette voix c'est qui a raté qui avait 17
et on le voit à la caméra qui est dans
le dur
il sait qu'il a perdu cette partie et
maxime qui revient complètement dans le
match puisqu'il va revenir à plus de
wesley qui va à l'essai tournez tournez
la pendule il a raison de toute façon la
partie est perdue il al avantage au
score celle avantage c'est le privilège
de prendre le lead et il a raison de
récupérer aussi un petit peu un de
laisser tourner s'égrainer les seconds
maxime qui doit prendre son temps quand
même et il a joué tranquille ne pas ne
pas jouer à toute blinde bien s'assurer
de ne pas faire d'erreurs mais ça va
gagner y restera dix minutes 9 minutes
peut-être plus tôt il va rester neuf
minutes à jouer et
et trois points d'écart là ça va ça va
aller aux mathes maxime qui m'a à toi c
qui s'est laissée mattei est quand même
assez fair play il abuse pas et deux
points d'écart dix minutes à jouer et
wesley qui continuent à être dans le dur
allait maxime allez allez il faut il
faut la gagner celle-là deux points
d'écart il reste probablement trois ou
quatre parties donc wesley qui est
encore sous la menace de maxime je vous
rappelle qu'en cas de match nul on
rejouera trois parties ou non ils ont
changé la règle ans et quatre parties 4
1 + 1 mais on va essayer de
de même gagné le match de mettre la
pression sur l'américain encore maxime
comme je vous le disais il encore le
droit à la nul mais il a probablement
plus le droit à la défaite et a souligné
le caractère très sportif de wesley qui
a joué quelques pouces était normale
mais qui n'a pas tenté de résister au
maximum il allait se faire mater
volontairement et donc wesley qui est un
joueur très sport très respectueux et
très respectable donc ils envoient h 4 h
5 peut-être cavalier e 5 maintenant pour
les blancs kg 5
c'est une structure de type carlsbad les
noirs veulent jouer b4 pour attaquer ll
dam des blancs les blancs qui veulent
attaquer les droits la position qui pour
le moment semble encore assez équilibré
pour pour pour les deux joueurs f6
peut-être maxime qui va vouloir essayer
de jouer avec du vieux 5 c'est fait et
là ça va être à double tranchant tour g3
et menace le pion g6 f5 et pas jouable à
cause de dame prend et sur quatre on
donnerait la case f4 donc on n'a pas
envie de le faire maxime qui encore 40
secondes qui a décidé de jouer le 4 il a
peut-être une idée après d'amd de houda
me 3 n'ont pas spécialement d'idées il
va laisser la case f4 et et jouets et
jouer cette position peut-être d'un f4
ici une idée parce que sur dan franck
cavallier prend on menacera deux pions
donc maxime qui va être obligé de
reculer la dame aimait il empêche de f5
donc ça c'est une bonne opération
et finalement la dame blanche qui fait
pas grand chose en f4 et l'a peut-être
rien de mieux à faire que de repartir
alors il fait tour 3 attention aux clés
parce que cavagnoud 6 à sa gagnera pas
de dames
il y aura des médecins qui fait f3 et
cavaliers aussi si la dame f5 encore qui
va mais roy et 7
il n'y avait pas une dame qui se perdait
1,27 et cavaliers g5 peut-être c'était
chaud tout un maxime qui défend qui
prend 4,34 prend le 4.4 la dame qui
repart en f3 les idées de cavaliers f4
attention adam prend h5 qui menace aussi
sur cavaliers aussi son app altoria
d'impro h5 intermédiaire 25 secondes de
chaque côté ça va être très serré c'est
une partie on sent qu'elle est qu'elle
est importantissime à siwel c'est la
gagne il va quand même faire le break
il revient à y reprendre trois points
d'avancé bien jouer maxime d'amd 6 ils
empêchent damage 5 il empêche dame
5 grâce à dame pranger trois dames f2 du
coup de la part de wesley qui empêche
tout re un cavalier e sisman entourent
f3 f5 g3 ouais c'est qui va envoyer
peut-être un cavalier angers 5 n'en a
laissé sans voix b5 bekhadda me 7
il ya peut-être à huy sur cavaliers f4
piège t3f 4 tours f4 et à tours 2 ouais
c'est qui fait damer fin c'est peut-être
même le roi des blancs manenti en danger
damas trois et vient attaquer de l'autre
côté cavalier abdou dames 3 de clouage
maxime qui est en train de prendre le
devant dans cette partie maxime qui est
en train de prendre le dessus
d'apprendre d'un pro ii d'amd trois ans
en os les sur sur le reculoir dame e2c
bien jouer d'un bien il va essayer de
donner d échec par derrière
wesley maxime qui va faire tour trois
dames bessette leroy monde dames prend
des cinq protège la tour c'est bien
jouer la finale le pion à qui est en
voie leroy qui vient couvrir le cavalier
en b katia les pions des deux côtés il
ya des pions liés de l'autre c'est
difficile de dire qui va l'emporter et
maxime je suis quand même content qu'il
ait pions pas s'éloigner mais il ya les
pions passé lié de l'autre côté le roi
qui va où est le cavalier qui va revenir
en d6 qui va tout arrêter
le cavalier géant de maxime maxime qui
va revenir à un point
le cavalier qui arrête tout et on a du
mal à voir comment wesley cavaliers p4
quand même pour apprendre qu'un essai de
haut calibre en à 3o c'est moche
wesley qui récupère le pion et
maintenant c'est nul assez moche ça le
cavalier doit c'est qui va pouvoir tout
sauver ou pas elle et elle est difficile
à jouer quand même en bullet celle là
pour les blancs même si elle est censée
être nulle aurillac avaler pour un f3
maintenant os les qui s'en sort
ouais c'est qu'ils s'en est sorti c'est
vraiment ça se joue à rien ce match deux
points d'écart cinq minutes 30 qui reste
deux parties quelle défense de wesley à
impressionnant solide superbe partie
ouais elle était archi gagnante sur
gagnante mais wesley qui a défendu comme
un lion comme un lion il reste
maintenant encore deux parties c'est
encore faisable pour le joueur français
qui n'a que deux points d'écart à l'est
il a choisi de jouer un genre de système
de londres hybride il va attaquer droit
et va mettre le cavagnan aux cinq mètres
le pion à f4 la position et est encore
correcte pour maxime la partie est parti
pour durer un lacet là il va falloir la
gagner parce que ça va pas être une
victoire qui va nous laisser du plus
puisqu'une partie derrière il y en aura
qu'une derrière et donc c'est décisif
allait maxime il va falloir attaquer la
jouer tranquille toute façon là qui
gagne vite ou pas ça change rien il va
falloir construire cette victoire met le
cavalier e 5 jouer pour g4 jouait pour
la taxe sur le roi envoyés et nous faire
rêver d'une dune dernière partie dans
laquelle il pourrait il pourrait
égaliser et revenir au score en tout cas
il pourra regretter un ce passage à vide
en 5 + 1 où il a complètement tilt et où
il a fait cadeau sur cadeaux il aurait
peut-être dû prendre plus son temps mais
on n'en est pas là x 4 excellent coup
ils menacent france et si ces cavaliers
ou cinq qui va lui assurer un avantage
stratégique énorme à long terme
et là il va pouvoir la jouer pendant
longtemps elle est pas gagnante en soi
mais c'est un grand avantage qu'on va
pouvoir jouer pendant trente quarante
cinquante coups avec le bon cavalier
contre le mauvais fou ou essayer qui va
essayer d'échanger peut-être sur la
colonne b jouer la finale tenir
graduellement essayé petit à petit de
résister il reste 3 minutes 30
mais trois minutes trente il va pas
pouvoir la jouer c'est là il n'y a pas
assez de temps matériel à la pendule
donc wesley qui va pas pouvoir empêcher
une autre partie en tout cas à la baisse
les qui pour le moment je joue vraiment
bien
il a mis le pion en b 5 pour colmater la
colonne b il a mis la tour en a3 la dame
en a cinq
et maintenant il dit à maxime comment tu
veux
regret c'est maxime qui ramène petit à
petit le roi en b1 pour protéger le pion
mais ouais c'est qu'il ya vraiment très
rapidement trouver un système défensif
excellent et maxime qui va devoir
réfléchir
wesley qui a proposé nul c'est courageux
mais parce qu'il est en train de la
jouer un peu
j'ai pas envie terre à l'intox mais il
est en train de la jouer lui dire ok
t'es mieux mais je sais comment défendre
sa est la maxime est obligé de jouer la
gagne
ils envoient eux quatre ils obligés
d'envoyer deux pions mais c'était
vraiment bien joué et d'avoir mis la
tour en b6 et d'avoir mis ce plan b 5
excellente défense de wesley il reste
combien de temps il reste 2 minutes 40
dans le match il faut gagner ça mais
c'est ingagnable tourbe et troyes et
tours b 2 échecs et wesley qui va
prendre le pion il va peut-être même
faire j'ai 5 ha ben non
allez maxime qui montrent le roi c'est
sa dernière chance
c'est la dernière cartouche du joueur
français là il faut absolument gagner
mais ça semble vraiment impossible même
tour b3 ici est la ilaha illa il a
beaucoup de pions de retard et j'ai du
mal à voir comment comment il peut aller
l'emporter ouest et qui prend le pion
passer de l'autre côté maxime qui
abandonnent et wes des sceaux qui
remporte ce match
maxime qui titille fait h5 le match le
match remporté par os les sauts mais
quelle quelle performance du joueur
américain et maxime qui pourra s'en
mordre les doigts
il pourra s'en mordre les doigts de ses
parties données en 5 + 1 quand il a
perdu 2 3 parties la ilaha illa pas
inapte à serrer le jeu il a il a fait
cadeau il a fait des cadeaux
il a perdu quelques parties en deux
trois minutes et
c'est dommage wesley qui va gagner ce
match qui réunit 43 points d'écart c'est
fini maxime qui sait pas forcément
combien de temps il reste exactement
mais avec trois points de moins il sait
que c'est terminé
ah c'est dommage on y aura cru mais
finalement dû l'être il aura pas réussi
à apprendre apprendre davantage sur
wesley qui a qui aura été impérial
écouter les mecs c'est un peu un peu
décevant maxime une nouvelle fois qu'il
se fait éliminer en speech est ce par un
joueur américain il a perdu plusieurs
fois contredit car où il perd ce soir
contre away c'est un match qui aura un
goût amer parce qu'on aura senti joueurs
français qui pouvait faire mieux
vraiment bon après c'est pas c'est pas
le plus important on espère qu'ils se
qualifiera aucun candidat à jérusalem on
sera évidemment là pour pour le suivre
sur thiès comme en direct les mercis up
du coup pour le seul sur sur ma chaîne
sur ma chaîne switch merci merci en tout
cas c'est une belle partie n'oubliez pas
que le 23 on a notre notre soirée à 21h
donc j'aurai peut-être pas mal de gens
du tchad qui étaient là ce soir on se
rencontrera le 23 ce sera cool match un
match frustrant finalement sauf qui a
serré qui a serré le jeu au bon moment
au dernier au dernier moment je dirais
au moment où maxime est revenue à plus
ça on a vraiment pensé que le joueur
français allait revenir vraiment
vraiment et finalement et finalement ça
n'a pas été le cas
mais j ai vraiment cru un
personnellement j'ai vraiment cru
là forcément la partie anecdotique
maxime va la gagner mais il ya plus de
temps
mais qu'un seul deux sets gagnants
ç'aurait été différent et ça aurait été
différent maxime qui gagne mais le match
est terminé 17 17 15
l'algorithme qui prévoyaient un score à
peu près comme celui-là c'est dommage
c'est dommage ouais le 5 + 1 est
vraiment dommage on va voir un petit peu
ouais naf et demie 6 3 5 et demi quatre
et demi mais c'est la presse dommage un
match vraiment un beau match et
l'algorithme qui prévoyait pas un
scénario comme ça non c'est un beau
match et montrent le moment du match
c'est quoi le moment du match du coup
d'après eux trois mais toute façon
c'était nul sur f2 y'avait kg trois
cavaliers ash ouais c'est vrai que sow
en sauvant cette finale c'est ça qui lui
a offert le match finalement ouais ouais
non c'était c'était difficile je vais
voir jeu voir ce qu'on écrit partout je
pensais peut-être prendre mag maximum
d'interviews s'il avait gagné mais là du
coup alors j'essaierai de lui prendre
une interview en rapport pour youtube en
rapport sur au dernier au dernier gp en
fait ouais je penserai plus opportun
elle a perdu un match un match difficile
par envie de pas envie de le prendre je
n'aime pas trop parler aux joueurs comme
ça après une défaite faut laisser
digérer surtout qu'ils avaient plusieurs
défaites consécutives donc je voulais
une petite pub on peut on peut continuer
à discuter cinq minutes quand même après
ce beau match on nous écrit sur youtube
le prix première partie en cinq puissant
et c'était horrible
ouais c'est ça en fait celle à qui perd
le match mais c'est en 5 courses 1 il
faut aussi suivre ma chaîne perso du
coup juste en dessous vous avez lien
n'hésitez pas à suivre aussi ma chaîne
ma chaîne perso sur youtube
du coup vous pouvez regarder les
dernières parties pédagogique
ça fait toujours plaisir ça fait
toujours plaisir
follow la chaîne chaise comme aussi bien
évidemment et ça je pense que vous
l'avez déjà fait
je vais faire un raid verte chaise comme
mais en tout cas c'était un beau match à
steinbourg une belle fin de match
c'était sympa je suis bien j'ai plus de
voix plus de souffle demain je vais bien
dormir là aujourd'hui
après le match d'hier le stream et tout
jeter j'étais dans l'eau mesure voilà je
vais je passer une bonne nuit
ouais c'est fini quoi zac
malheureusement ce sera vraiment joué
sur la première sur la première sur la
première 90 minutes de match
c'est là que ça se sera que ça se sera
passé et c'est la pls apparaît donc je
vais vous envoyer un raid vers la chaîne
duchess comme histoire que vous puissiez
suivre les interviews et un peu la page
de pub c'est quand même sympa de la
suivre histoire de sorte que chess comme
s'y retrouvent aussi non sans arrêter ça
aurait été une belle une belle soirée
malheureusement un poil short un poil
nigel sera un beau match en 2001
artemiev saut ce sera serré un bon après
si maxi maxi mail et numéro quatre
mondial il gagne des points elo il fait
une belle année mais sexy radis rusal m
il il aura fait poteau sortant à tous
les trucs quoi il reste en fait le
dernier quart de finale ça va être du
dana camurat qui rencontreront
nepomniachi en demi et de l'autre côté
du tableau ce sera so contre artemiev la
demie donc ce sera sûrement naka contre
comptes rené peau et artemiev conso
donc je vais vous envoyer le raid
histoire que vous puissiez suivre et
nous on va se retrouver plus tard
merci à tous en tout cas et je pense je
dis peut-être un stream ont en tout cas
vendredi et samedi pour la soirée
merci à tous d'avoir suivi et on va
garder le sourire c'est un beau match on
a vécu un beau moment parfois ça passe
parfois ça passe pas mais on a vécu un
beau match c'est quand même le plus
important on a vibré
sap a tourné sa pas tourner rond ça
tournera jérusalem ce pas grave merci à
tous bonne soirée ciao ciao